Oh, that's, oh, sorry.
Whoa, sorry, crashed your school.
That's right.
I robbed you of your loops.
No loop for you.
I got my coffee right now, too.
Good news.
I have not had a nap yet.
Bad news.
I've been awake since 6 in the morning.
So I got my coffee.
I'm going to try.
I'm going to try to stay up this time.
I'm going to.
I'm gonna try and this is actually the first time I've been
able to stay up for a while so I got actually I got my
coffee right now so I'm gonna do my best I haven't slept yet
um but that means if I make it if I make it I might be able
to finally fix my sleep schedule it's gonna be a
breakthrough we're gonna have a breakthrough today this is
the day guys today's the day also I know chat is dead I'm
trying to fix it right now uh today is the day I got my
copy.
Let's see.
All right, let me look at some stuff real quick.
All right.
Sorry.
The reason why we're on this screen right now is because we
have a lot of updates, life updates, stream updates, lots of
stuff going on behind the scenes.
You might have noticed I didn't tweet out the announcement
right away for the conference.
For those who were wondering what the big announcement was
two days ago with Chibi, Chibi-Doki and I are doing a
concert, a 3D concert on July 4th, which is also my
birthday!
Yeah!
That was the big announcement.
And then right after that announcement stream, I went to
sleep.
I literally went to sleep.
I was like, yeah!
Everything is done now!
Instead of tweeting up the and capitalizing on the hype I
just went to bed I was just so happy it's finally out there
and then I just went to bed um and then the next day you
know I could have just tweeted it out I was like I'm just
gonna tweet out the next day I'm gonna tweet out tomorrow
and then I was only awake for four hours like yesterday yeah
job done like should I try and uh do some advertising to
sell my tickets.
No, I'm gonna go to sleep.
I get it.
I know you guys are, I was so fucking tired.
I think like, after announcing everything, finally having it
out there, like, everything just caught up to me.
Like, all the sleepless, like, all the days I did sleep a
lot.
All the stress.
Everything I was building up.
I finally, I was just like, I'm gonna sleep now.
I'm gonna, it's out there now.
I'm gonna rest.
It's now out in the world and I hibernated really hard.
So I basically went, like yesterday on my rest day, I
literally just been awake for only four hours.
So did you feed?
Yes, I would, I just walked, feed him, go back to sleep,
wake up, feed him, walk, go back to sleep.
Well, I would stand for four hours.
So in between those times, I had a chance to, you know, take
care of my dog uh but then like i was so tired i was like
okay i'm gonna get all the stuff done i'm gonna go tweet the
thing up but then i was like oh no it's 10 p it's 11 p.m
like what's the point of tweeting out the concert when when
it's so late i might as well wait the next day to tweet out
the concert during prime hours you know that's how i justify
i was like i should i might like what's the point i might as
well wait till tomorrow you know i've been up since 6 a.m i
had so much work stuff today you guys know there's a lot of
announcements i told you guys april you guys must have been
like oh that the concert that's why it was her hell no there
were so many other things going on behind the scenes um oh
my god where do i start because that's why i'm here right
going straight to pragmata also that's why i'm also for this
one wondering why i'm not streaming the mouse game i've been
craving i wanted to play more pragmata because like um i
didn't want to do like a gap in between like you know
there's a gap game in between um i've just been itching to
play more pragmata because i've been enjoying it a lot i
enjoyed it a lot during the last stream i just want to
continue it anyway before i go guys thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you congrats to be a good adult example
for your child by not wasting the day napping thank you for
Thank you.
All right, where do I wanna start?
There's so many things.
I do wanna tell you guys more about like the LA trip and
everything because I wanted to talk more about it between
like why I was gone on Friday and Saturday and stuff like
that.
All right, so this was just announced.
But not only do we have a concert on July 4th, we also have
an Anime Expo, Mean and Greet and Panel.
Panel has not yet been announced on the official Twitter
account yet, But if you guys didn't notice, because like
Snuffy and Duby were announced already, I was just announced
for the meet and greet like seven minutes ago.
So the thing is, you guys might be in there.
It's like, whoa, like where did all these VTubers come from
for Anime Expo?
Because I don't know if they'd done meet and greets for
Anime Expo before for VTubers.
I don't know.
Maybe they have.
I just can't remember if they have or not.
But my event staff got me meet and greet spots and also a
panel slot for Anime Expo.
And she was like, oh, we have, do you want to invite any
VTubers?
Because we have five slots.
So that means there's two more VTubers that have yet to be
announced yet.
We announced all the ones today.
There's going to be more announcements, I believe, tomorrow
on the last two.
so I was like oh you know why don't we invite Duby and
Snuffy since like like you know my man like she has my
manager now so we share a manager together because I
recommended my manager to her so so like we share she shares
some of my staff members too so I was just like oh yeah like
um why don't we invite Duby along and Snuffy along as well
so that's why they're also doing the the meet and greed uh
with me so well you know the mean greets are individual but
like they also have a meeting greet slot because uh like i
said huge shout out to my event manager uh we she gave me
like five uh like she gave me like five in four invites
basically including me it would be five she gave me she gave
me four invites to invite some of my v2 friends and i was
just like oh okay let me just hit up doobie if she wants to
join me uh so that's why doobie and stuff here joining me uh
for meeting greets as well uh and but yeah it's gonna be on
july 3rd which is the day before the concert so if you're
gonna be at anime expo on july 3rd uh there's gonna be a
bunch of meeting greets um bunch well five vtuber meeting
greets maybe there's more i don't know but i just know on my
side there's five including me uh let me post the picture
real quick it was literally just announced like seven
minutes ago for the panel for the panel it it All I can say
is that for the panel, I might have invited some sloppy
sisters to join me for the panel.
On July 3rd, we just actually confirmed it today, being like
everybody, like looking at everybody's availabilities.
So, so subtle.
so we're a panel it'll be i don't know the timing of it
because it hasn't been fully announced yet anime expo but i
might as well tell you guys right now uh just because like
so you guys know this is all on july 3rd by the way uh july
3rd this is all gonna be on july 3rd and then panel will be
like with the sloppy sisters and the meeting greet will be
it's individual meeting greets so uh so right now they've
announced me do be and snuffy so um uh this is all going to
be on july 3rd and july 4th will be uh will be my concert uh
but but that's not an anime expo it's uh it's off venue it's
a different venue so you don't need an anime expo ticket to
go to my concert but you do need an animal expo you do need
an anime expo ticket if you want to go if you want to do the
meet and greet or the panel i just i just need to let you
guys know that like So, just a little warning that you do
need an Anime Expo ticket.
We are coming to Anime Expo to participate in the meeting
grade and also the panel as well.
I'm so thankful that you're doing streaming tickets for the
concert since I'll be stuck home in charge of 4th of July.
My work show for my family.
Thank you for the super chat, but thank you, thank you.
Yeah, like, it's still a work in progress, so I hope the
streaming tickets will be ready soon for you guys.
Because I know, you know, it's very expensive.
I just found out that it's apparently the 250th.
anniversary of America during my during my birthday you know
because I can't god damn it why does everyone want to
schedule stuff on my birthday I mean I was here first so the
timing couldn't be more perfect I guess uh not only is there
a world cup uh a world cup in LA but there's also it's
anniversary of America, and they also apparently are having
a concert as well in LA somewhere.
God, they have like, they're so inconsiderate.
I know it's my birthday came first.
They're so inconsiderate.
Like,
session with Hollow in LA too.
It's so awkward because I didn't know they were going to
have a concert in LA as well.
So when it was announced, I was just like, S-O-S, what the
fuck do we do?
Because I was like, so I was like, can we, I would really
like it if we don't overlap with this concert.
Luckily, the time has yet to be decided.
Thank God.
So I was just like, all right, I'm going to get the
afternoon.
That's why my concert's in the afternoon.
Because I was like, I was like, I really, really wish to not
overlap with anyone.
So my timing couldn't be more impeccable for this concert.
No, it doesn't overlap.
Our concert's at the afternoon and there's are at the
evening.
So like, if anything, you guys have like, for those who
aren't going to go, try to go to both concerts or three
concerts, who knows?
Maybe you want to go to the 250th anniversary America
concert in the middle between, you know, it's up to you
guys.
You go to the dokey dokey rewind time, then go to America's
birthday party and then go straight to the last concert.
Like, it's up to you guys.
It's all, it's all up to you.
If you want to do all three in one day, uh but with all in
la always has been doug thank you this super chat thank you
thank you thank you cluel thank you this super chat thank
you thank you july 3rd is my birthday i'm looking forward to
seeing you thank you super chat cluel thank you thank you um
so yes uh it's it was scheduled in a way where you have at
least one to two hours to commute in between so um so um i
try to make It was like accommodating for everybody like I
said I was very stressed out I was I was very stressed out
with the whole thing with the whole planning of all of this
Because I was like does it have to be on July 4th When I
found out more and more stuff is appearing on that day I was
just like does it have to be on July 4th.
I was just like, guys.
But it had to be.
We made a commitment to the venue.
We were ready.
We couldn't.
I was sealed in.
At least there's no Olympics.
At least the Olympics is not there.
can't change your birthday.
It's your birthday.
Yeah, but for some reason, someone else decided to celebrate
their birthday at the same day as me.
America.
Yeah, why don't we postpone America's birthday instead?
You had 250 years.
This is my...
year.
Like, they're so rude.
I know.
It's my, I, this is only my fifth birthday.
Not even, this is only my third birthday.
So true.
Um, anyway, there was, there's that too.
But yes, I'm really looking forward to the meeting.
I saw a lot of people were very excited when, uh, Duby and
Snuffy's announcements were posted.
People were like, what?
Oh my God.
They're going to be like, to be an adamant expo and i was
like i did that i was like so i was like oh my god i was so
happy i know it was just really nice to see everybody like
super excited about it and everything and made me like super
happy because i was like oh i did that it's just nice to see
well i didn't do it my event manager shout out to my event
manager she did it she's like she did it like i did it but I
asked.
I invited.
Yeah.
So huge shout out to my event manager for organizing all of
this stolen valor.
She's really, really good at her job.
That's all.
I can't really...
She was actually there.
She actually accompanied me to LA during...
when I had to like, uh, uh, go, sorry, my, my, the coffee's
kicking in right now.
Uh, when I had to visit the studio and stuff and go over
like production stuff and the planning of the concert and
like some of the motion capture, like going through the
motion, like testing out motion capture and stuff like that.
Um, I was originally gonna be had to, had to go alone
because my, my manager who's, uh, from, uh, from EU couldn't
fly in because he's like i'm from you so so obviously you
couldn't you couldn't come over um so i was like very
nervous and i was like sort of crashing out because uh
originally he was supposed to fly over but uh in the end it
was it didn't came to be um something came up so then i was
crashing out and i was freaking out because i didn't want to
fly alone and i was really nervous because like They were
people, like, um, the people, the, I never met the concert
organizers before in person, and I was really nervous,
especially, you know, as a YouTuber, because I was like, oh,
like, you know, I had to show myself and stuff like that, so
I was very scared, and I was like, I got super anxious and
everything, and I was like begging my magic, please, can you
please come over, like, I'm pleased, I don't want to be
alone, and then he was like, look, how about we fly over
the, event manager because she lives closer and um and I was
just like I will take anything like I don't I just need
someone there I don't want to talk like because like I also
was like super anxious and introverted and I was like really
worried about talking to people too I just want to go there
do my job and then like peace out I don't I didn't really
want to do small talk or anything because I was just, I was
just very, very stressed out.
I was very stressed out and I was like crashing out.
And I really was not, I was, I didn't feel like interacting
with anyone by I have to.
And then I was just like, oh, I don't want to be alone.
And then so luckily my event manager was like, yeah, I can
take, because like she does this as like a side thing.
So she has an actual job.
But luckily she said like, I work at home.
So I can like, I'm just going to pretend that I'm at home
when I'm in LA.
like she was like well how many magic well she's my event
manager so she handles all the events that i do like she
connects me to like because like she's actually um i'm
really thankful to have her because uh she actually runs a
lot of like big conventions not like vtuber stuff but like
she runs a lot of big like na conventions around like around
like and around Canada, basically.
So some of the big Canadian conventions, she's like one of
the lead event runners for them.
So, and she's well connected to like American, to American
conventions and Canadian conventions.
Like this, she's connected to like the staffing around,
around NA.
So, so she's my head event manager.
So that's why I'm able to be in like, that's why I was able
to get
Didn't have to pay anything.
It was more, like, I'm not getting paid.
And also, didn't have to pay Anime Expo to get in.
Because apparently, from what I was told for Anime Expo,
usually, you have to pay a lot to be, like, venue there and
everything to be, like, a guest there.
So luckily, I didn't have to pay Anime Expo.
I'm not being paid by Anime Expo to do it.
But it's more so, like, marketing for exposure type deal.
There's a lot of people that are going to anime expo like a
lot of dragoons that are going there So I was like, why not,
you know, I'm already doing concert.
I'm already doing a concert in In LA anyway, like I might as
well, you know, so a huge shout out to my event manager and
for like
For being there for me in LA when I had to like go fly there
to for the concert like to set like like fuck sorry words
are so hard right now and like my brain is so scattered i'm
like you don't understand that concert really fucked me up
that that concert really fucked me up guys um and meet the
organizers and like uh and like direct like how i wanted the
motion capture and try the motion capture at their studio
there uh just to be sure like everything set up like how i
want things to be done and everything like just organizing
the whole concert stuff in person with the concert
organizers anyway so she was so nice it was actually my
first time meeting her like face to face with my event
organizer and uh it was so nice because like when i was like
testing of the motion capture stuff um after every take she
would come over and give me water like she would hold my
wall like you know it felt like a i felt like one of those
like celebrities at the set you know where the assistant
would come over there and get like hold the water bottle
with the straw and be like you want some water and i'll be
like yes i'll be like like a little hamster like yeah so and
just you want me to get you anything i was like yes
Oh, some of you guys actually might have already met my
event staff manager, too, because she, like I said, she's,
she, have you ever done like meet and greets or like came to
my panels?
You might have actually already met her because sometimes
she helps with, she oversees the meet and greets and also
oversees the panels, might even take in the panel pictures
too.
So some of you guys might have actually met her before too.
She was also taking me to places.
like showing me around LA as well and helping me with
ordering ubers and stuff and she didn't have to do this but
she took me to the airport early in the morning like I had
to be at the airport at around like 6 a.m.
and like I had to wake up at 6 a.m.
and had to go to the airport around like 6 30 or 7 a.m.
her flight wasn't until like 7 p.m.
or some shit and she was like oh i'll take you to the air
i'll keep take you to the airport and like uh chaperone you
to the airport and keep you company i was like oh thank you
and then you know my manager called me and was like how is
ever to make sure i'm alive you know and i was just like oh
how i was meeting her and everything and then i was like it
was great she took care of me like she talked to she helped
me talk to adults when i didn't want to talk she's and then
she knows how to be nice to people because sometimes i'm
like super direct in things because i'm tired and i'm when
i'm tired i'm a little grouchy and i don't really want to
talk to people and then she was like but she'll be like my
my talker and then like make me sound like you know like
sugarcoat everything like pr language you know she she was
in charge of the PR language to make everything sounds nice
um anyway so and then my manager my manager was like yeah we
sort of like what
Okay, she was like, yeah, like when we talk to each other,
you're sort of like our kid.
He was like, we're sort of like, we're sort of like, yes,
taking care of like our kid together.
And like the child.
You're like my, yeah.
They're like my babysitters.
Yeah.
They know what you are.
Oh, so good.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
Adventure sun rays.
So, yeah.
So it's like a child simulator, which is basically what I'm
going to be playing like soon.
Which is basically Pragmata.
But I'm their child simulator right now.
Anyway, so there's that.
There was that regarding the LA trip.
So tired.
I was so...
I realized I think during that trip I did not tweet about
anything.
It was just clock in and clock out.
And then I'm home now.
What else?
Yes, dad update.
I took dad to the dog park.
And it was so cute.
Because, like, the moment I went there, there was another
weiner dog.
There was another weiner dog at the park.
And then dad was so happy because he was like, same dog.
Same dog.
And then the other dog was, like, older.
Like, super old.
Like, they were, like, 13 or something.
So they weren't as excited as dad when they saw each other.
But he was like, oh, my God.
same dog the same dog so he was like super happy and like
like smelling the other wiener dog and then a shiba shiba
inu came over and dad was not happy he was like not same dog
not same i thought like you know i thought you know because
he saw another wiener dog he'd be a lot calmer and more
friendly and he was because it was the same dog but then the
inu came over and he's like not same same dog and he got
really mad he's like don't get close to me and it's like
he's racist i i don't know i know but like he got really mad
because like the shiba inu was like friendly and he wanted
to smell dad and then he walked over and um he walked over
and then he's like like trying to greet dad and then and
then you know he presented his ass for him for dad to smell
and dad smelled it and then like he looked back and then you
know he looked back at the shiba inu like face to face and
then the shiba inu thought like oh yeah we're friendly now
we're friends now right i let you smell my ass um and so he
got closer and then like they were like face to face and I
was like no he was like scared the shit of the Shiva because
he like he like baited him so hard he's like not same dog
not same dog get away
I was like I'm so sorry I thought he'd be friendly he was
friendly to to the other dog.
Um.
But yeah, that's pretty much that up there.
I guess I found out my dog's fucking racist.
I mean, not, I feel like we've already known.
I mean.
Anyway, today was the day I found out my dog was sort of
racist towards other dogs.
I what else oh yes nike sponsor uh like i said there's a lot
of stuff to talk about uh nike sponsor tomorrow that which
means there's no game dev tycoon stream tomorrow because uh
they rescheduled the nike sponsor to a lot earlier so um uh
before it was it was said to be they told us it was going to
be at 7 but now they've rescheduled it to 2 p.m so i'll be
streaming on twitch at 2 p.m which means i will have to
reschedule the uh tycoon the game dev tycoon game just
because i don't want to like rush one over the other like
you know be like oh it's too now i gotta go go over twitch
uh so we gotta push that another day is it's a watch alarm
for those who are
making fun of me be okay I'll give you guys a backstory of
this so basically it is this for if you guys don't remember
when in the beginning of April I said it's gonna be hell
month because sponsors know I would say yes to anything so
somebody so apparently someone dropped out last minute so
they were like Yoki will say yes to anything despite the
very, very tight deadline.
And they were right.
They were right because I will say yes to anything for
money.
And so you guys might notice why am I standing mad emoji?
Fitcher.
So, so I, Okay, so I didn't realize they were going to
publish this because when they sent us the draft, we gave
them, my manager gave them a folder of a bunch of PNGs.
They're like, do you have a PNG that you want to use for the
announcement?
And then my manager gave them a folder.
I just didn't think they would pick that one.
There was so many pictures in that folder.
I was just, I was just, I just didn't think they would pick
the default.
What?
So, so, anyway, so obviously, I was like, I saw that, and I
was like, um, can you, can you, I told my manager, can you
please ask them to change that?
Like, apparently, um, so, so, I don't know who, I don't know
where people got the first image, but it was out there.
I don't know where you guys got it.
but it got posted um so we were i guess it wasn't changed in
time um so now now it's not the default anymore now it's not
the default it's it's the it's an actual expressive uh pose
png um uh but yeah i i don't know where it came came from
like i don't know how you guys got the first one i just
didn't realize it was gonna be posted already before we made
the change uh
so uh and then i saw somebody were wondering like oh why are
you the only one streaming on twitch even though you're
you're the only one that has a youtube platform it's because
um i wanted to I only wanted to stream on one platform.
I didn't want to multi-stream because I rather, because like
everybody's streaming it.
So I was like, well, if everybody's streaming it, I'd rather
just have it on one platform instead of multi-stream.
And so I was like, YouTube or Twitch.
It was like, yeah, I picked YouTube or Twitch because my
person just didn't want to multi-stream because I wanted to
be like a one, because it's a big event.
So I was like, I want it only on one channel.
And I was like, we could have it on YouTube.
only but then apparently the concert uh main platform was on
twitch i believe i don't know if it's for drop i think it's
just for like it's an event so they wanted it to be on
twitch primarily so now i was like all right then i'll just
stream on twitch so that's why i'm the only one that has
like that's on twitch because i just i person it was just a
personal preference thing i just didn't want to multi-stream
so that's why it's on twitch um and what else uh yeah so
Yeah, so because they wanted the main platform to be on
Twitch itself What else is that I want to talk about?
Oh, yeah, for those who are wondering, it's a watchalong
That's why it was sort of like Hell Month Because I was
contacted last minute To be added to this event So they were
like It was like We need her to do this by the end of today
We need her to send submit this by tomorrow.
We need her to record for this in two days So while I was
doing the concert prep I had to record a song and also the
dance stuff within like three to four days So I'm just like
oh my god, and then the short the YouTube short that was
uploaded was literally completed This morning
Because it was, I was so, I was, I was so stressed out
because I got a message from a manager.
They're like, everyone else has submitted the recording, but
you.
And I was like, I was so fucking stressed out.
They're like, we really need your recording.
Everyone else has submitted their stuff.
You're the only one left.
And I was like, I was given the lyrics yesterday.
What do you mean?
I...
I was just like, what do you mean?
I was sent the information yesterday.
So, um, so I was very stressed out.
Like, because I was also trying to make through everything.
I was also, like, working on, um, the concert stuff along.
side the sponsor so uh so I was freaking out that's why I
was having like breakdowns and crying because I had to and I
almost took another sponsor there was almost there was
almost a third sponsor that was also related to singing and
performing and I I I was like we should take that because
they were also like we need someone last minute I was like
that's a lot of money I wish I'd take it.
And then my man is just like Doki, please don't do this.
He's like, Doki, please.
He was trying so hard to make up excuses for me not to do
it.
And he's like, please do Doki, you are having, you had a
breakdown last night, Doki.
And I was like, yeah, but I'm okay now though.
I was like, but yeah, I'm okay now.
I think I can do this.
I think I do this.
He's like, Like, wait, no, I'm pretty sure I can do this.
I'm okay now.
I took you one.
Elle, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Student photo versus gravity model.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I was greedy.
I was just like, oh my God.
It'd be so cool.
Yeah, I was like, future don't you can worry about that.
In the end, it's gonna look so cool.
I actually don't know what it looks like.
They were like, you're gonna be, they wanna surprise us in
the watch alarm because we're reacting to it.
So it's basically a concert.
So I have no idea what it's looked like.
I don't know what it sounds like.
I just found out when they released a graphic who was in the
concert.
I just, because they kept it a secret.
So it was like a surprise type deal.
And I don't know, or I don't know, maybe it's because I was
a last minute edition.
so i didn't know but um matara knew matara knew i was in it
and because i because she was like i saw but i was like i
was like because like uh we were talking because you know we
both have the she's day one i'm day three for the concert so
we were talking about so like you guys might have seen the
clip where um i was giving her advice for motion capture and
then she was like i was like oh yeah i'm doing this song and
she's like i saw i wanted to do that song and then i was
like Because I was like, I don't even know who's in it.
Like, I was just, I was like, what do you mean?
I, like, this is news to me.
I literally just found out that you were in it because we
were talking about Nikkei.
What do you mean, you saw?
So, so I think it's just because I was the last minute
edition that I don't know what the fuck is going on.
Other than I submitted my stuff, I...
What?
How does she know?
Yeah, I was just like, how do you know?
Like, maybe you saw.
I'm so confused.
I just literally found out 10 seconds ago that you were in
it.
And then you knew from the beginning?
Like...
So...
So, and I found out everyone else that was in it through the
graphics.
Oh, that's everyone that's in it.
The simple thing with Super Chat, thank you.
Thank you.
It's that you think you make all this money for a dog that
loves this theater more than you.
The super chat, thank you.
Thank you.
So I'm super excited to watch the concert with you guys.
Like it's going to be like first hand experience for me as
well.
Like I said, like the only thing I knew is like what I
recorded.
That's all like what I recorded.
the raw vocals i i do not know like anything else like the
raw vocals and a bits of the motion capture stuff so like
that's really all i know so it's i'm going in blind just
like you guys but yeah please feel free to support the
sponsor the stream like i said work very hard on it um
especially with the very tight schedule i had to get
everything done and get me like submitted
I was like freaking out about all the stuff that was all
like combining together So there's that that I wanted to
talk about what else Let's see I wrote a lot of stuff.
Maybe I'll just remember it later
Just reading my notes real quick guys.
Oh, yeah, there is another thing I've read okay, I don't
know if you guys know about this restaurant chain but
there's a restaurant chain called chubby cattle that's in LA
there's four of them there's four chubby cattle restaurants
I don't know about it because there's one in little Tokyo I
was so sad because I missed the Pikmin AR event that was at
little Tokyo because by the time we left the studio my when
my event staff and I left the studio the Pikmin event ended
so I could not couldn't But anyway, so, uh, so there's, you
know, after my event staff member took me around Little
Tokyo, we wanted to go to the Chubby Cattle because it
smelled really good.
It was like, it's a Yaki Niku place.
And then, uh, because it smelled really, really good.
And we kept passing it.
And, uh, the wait was like, 90 minutes.
I was like, that's fucking crazy.
Because we're like, oh, maybe it's because of the Pikmin
event.
Like, everybody's just, you know, done walking around Little
Tokyo.
It's dinner time.
Everybody's just going to, like, the chubby cattle.
And I was like, this is a franchise.
Because I recognized chubby cattle in other cities before.
So I was like, there must be other chubby cattle around LA.
And then my mentor said, oh, that's smart.
Surely there's no lie.
So we called three other chubby cattle places.
And all of them was, like, 90-plus minute wait.
And I was like, There's all three chubby cattle.
There's four chubby cattle in LA.
And all four of them have 90 plus minute weight.
I don't understand.
It's distributed throughout LA.
So I never had a chance to try out chubby cattle.
I don't understand why there is like 90 plus minute weight
in all chubby cattle.
good one day maybe maybe oh i won't even get it in july 4th
the saddest part is that i know i won't even get the chance
to experience it on july 4th because it's someone else's
birthday too on that day and thing is because then you're
like oh maybe it's just every restaurant had a lot so then
we just went to Kura, like the sushi, the revolving sushi?
No line.
There's only one Kura in Little Tokyo.
I mean, I'm pretty sure there's multiple Kuras.
That's so rude of America.
No line at Kura, though.
There's a 90-plus minute line for four different chubby
cattle scattered around LA.
So, I'm a little sad I'm a little bit grouchy about that.
I really wanted to try out Chubby Cattle.
Alright, what else?
What else?
Oh yeah, what we're thinking about the concert.
I'm just glad I can finally talk about it.
I was so fucking stressed out.
There were so many roadblocks leading up to this concert.
Like, there was so many things happening for this concert.
There was like...
I had like, um, there was like, I think like two to three
songs.
Oh, there were two to three, two songs that got scrapped,
um, last minute because of perms, perms and stuff, um, when
it found out that we actually couldn't sing those songs.
Yeah, okay, I'll tell you guys one of them.
I was so sad.
I was looking forward to it.
But one of the songs that got scrapped last minute was
TikTok.
And I was so looking forward to seeing TikTok because it's
like, Every morning feeling like P-Ditty.
Not because of the P-Ditty part.
That's just so you guys.
It was just, it was just the right.
We weren't able to have it streamed online.
Like, not because of that.
But I was so sad because that was like one of the songs I
was so looking forward to seeing at the concert.
And, um, and then we found out, like, so last minute, like,
that it couldn't be sang, and I, like, was, like, two songs,
and I was, like, freaking out, because, you know, I had to
re-record the scratch audio, like, re-record more scratch
audio for it, and I was, like, already, like, you know,
planning the choreo and everything, and my, like, planning
the choreo for stuff like that.
So there's two songs and another of them.
I'll tell you guys another scrap song because, you know,
it's not going to be performed or anything.
But the other one was Space Jam.
It was, that was the other one.
And like I said, they were, don't worry.
We replaced Space Jam and TikTok with other bangers.
But I know it would have been so fucking cool.
We got Space Jam too.
But like I said, like I was stressed the fuck.
because I had to like figure out new replacement and
everything and then figure out the new choreo the like
record re-record some of the scratch audio for it um so that
the band can practice to it practice to the song and songs
and events yeah I was like come on a slam and welcome to the
don't worry there's still other peak songs with there we
have other bangers in there uh and uh so there's like stuff
like that we had like roblox like that and i was so fucking
oh my gosh i was so stressed out we're always like something
would happen and like uh and uh and it was just i just hope
i you know what i'd be happy if we sell 50 like i felt like
with everything that's like with everything
I'd be happy if we saw, if we get 50% tickets sold.
Because, like I said, like, you know, LA is very expensive
too.
And especially, like, with all the stuff going on right now
in LA as well.
So I understand, like, especially, I understand if, like,
people are like, I can't travel right now.
Like, and I understand that.
And I hope that streaming tickets will go well because of
that.
Like, I was really pushing very hard for streaming tickets.
and they're still negotiating they're so like making the
deal for it so like i'm like i'm like we have to have
streaming tickets because i want to be more accessible and
have it be super accessible and accommodating to everyone
around the world too because like traveling is very
expensive right now and i get that too so i'm i'm just like
i'm just glad like most of the hard stuff is done
I'm just so happy that most of the really hard stuff is now
done and now it's just I'm just cruising along like I'm just
I'm just cruising along to the finish line which is in three
months away um um but there's a lot of exciting things uh
for that I Guest announcements are going to be like, I think
the first guest will be announced in, oh my God, I've been
yapping for an hour, I'm sorry.
But the first guest for the concert will be announced in, I
think, like, two days, I believe.
I was trying to push it to be announced earlier.
At first, they were like, let's drop it all at once, the
organizers.
And I was like, no.
We got to edge it out.
And we had to stagger the release, slowly build hype as we
go.
We got edge the release of the guests.
Because they're like, why don't we drop all the guests on
once?
I was like, no, we got to drift feed it.
We cannot drop it all.
I know, I was like, we cannot do that all at once.
We got to stagger the releases to build the hype more and
more.
so um so i i'm very excited like i said some of the guests
are singing more than one song so it's not like oh it's just
one song and done uh we have like some guests are singing
two to three songs in the concert like it was either like
you know duets or group songs stuff like that so just
something to look forward to and like i said like i spent a
lot of money my own personal money on the concert Like I
said, the two new outfits for 3D and other stuff.
Custom choreo.
Custom choreo for the songs, I had to pay out of my own
pocket.
Because they're like, oh, you can do vibe dancing.
And I was like, I can't do...
I mean, there is a song that I'm playing.
Like, there is like one or two songs that I'm playing.
I'm doing vibe dancing because I can't fucking do custom
choreo for everything.
But I did pay for custom choreo.
pay to have a custom choreo made for some of the songs as
well so oh my god I cannot wait for you guys to see it uh
and that is also why I've been very very tired I've been
very very tired but like I said oh I I'm very proud of of
being with like I this was the most involved I've ever been
in a Like, for, like, Phantom Thief, and for the birthday
concert, I wasn't as involved as for this one.
I was involved with a lot of the steps leading up to, like,
the announcement of stuff, announcement for this concert.
Like, for the Phantom Thief, it was, like, more so, like,
they're, like, come up with a set list.
And then, like, travel for the motion capture.
and the choreo and then that was it like they're like don't
worry we can handle everything else like and i was like
sweet oh my god concerts are so easy like i thought i was
like damn concerts are so fucking easy i just need to come
up with four songs and that's it
yeah i got to play mob of rival still and it's not it's not
it's i was just a bystander for that i thought wrong it's
not easy it's not now that i was more personally involved
for this one it's not easy i there were many days where
literally the my manager like i need we need to call right
now to go through stuff i was like do not call me.
I was like, I was like, I told my manager, I was like, do
not call me.
I am very depressed right now.
I am very depressed right now, and I am very moody.
Do not call me.
And then he called me, and I was like, I told you not to
call me.
Now I will yell at you.
And he was like, I knew what I knew what I was getting into,
but I really needed you to tell you this.
And I was like, I am sorry, I'm very mad right now.
Don't keep, no.
I warned him.
I fucking warned him.
I was like, do not call me.
for because it was to be fair he needed to tell me stuff
about the nike stuff about the youtube short because we're
like you have to we are still trying to figure out how to do
this youtube short so so he really needed my answer but i
literally warned him before he called me before i even knew
i had a call i was like i was like good morning i am very
depressed and i'm very
And then he's like, I need to call you.
Cyber, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Do not bother the beast.
But that was one of the days where it got really, where it
got like really fucking bad.
Because like I said, I was so stressed out.
I was so not feeling.
it like do not poke the beast like yeah business business
still moves on even if i was very moody all right anyway all
right now we can play pragmata i gave you guys i'm pretty
sure i'm missing some life update stuff like i said there
was a lot of stuff going on um uh so we'll just we'll just
go in if i remember maybe i'll maybe i'll remember the other
things i want to talk about let's see all right pragmata
time i always want i wonder if like it's funny because i see
like a lot of people's reactions to pragmata and people are
like i want kids now Or like, oh my gosh, I want to start a
family after your product.
But I wonder if this is like a site.
What's it called?
A site ops.
Is that how you pronounce it?
To just for people to be like, gotta start a family.
Like,
they're like, oh my god.
Yeah, take Korea.
Alright.
I wonder if I have the DLC.
No, I don't think so.
I feel like it would show if I did.
Alright.
His legacy lives on.
His final plan.
Alright.
Also, SoundGab, you're here.
Let me know if the sound's okay.
Because I did...
I upped the volume a little bit.
Next time you need to yell at someone, I'm right here for
it, Mr. Broken Bond.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
God, I really do not like this level, though.
I really am... Sorry, I'm not a fan of the tree level,
surprisingly.
No way to thought.
I was like, don't worry.
When the world needed it most, they released Pragmata.
No, I did, but I realized it was, like, a bit too quiet.
So, not too quiet, but, like, it could be a little louder.
So, I up the volume a little bit.
So, I just need SoundGuard to know if it's okay.
Alright, I think I still remember how to play.
I just, I don't know.
I just don't like this particular level.
Only because, uh, I collabed 3% at Chris.
Oh, we need that, actually.
Increase attack power within the increased hacking range.
Okay, I do not have enough.
that it just has too much grass i don't like the tear i
don't fuck with the terror dome it's just it it's hard to
move it's hard to i just don't like the level design for it
because everything looks too similar for this one i like the
other first to like new york city and then the the space
station for this one it's just everything seems to blend in
together i'm not a huge fan of it yeah which one is i see is
that too much grass nine out of five i'm basically ign right
now oh oh oh shit give me a sec i forgot how to play oh fuck
whoa
Okay, whoops.
Alright, that's fine.
Nice.
Alright, uh, charge for your ceremony as well.
Wait, what is that?
Gen chip.
Alright, time to eat your ram!
It's snacky time!
Gen chip!
Two more left.
Hope it doesn't take too long.
Alright, oh hey, nice.
We got another earth memory.
filled with helium these balloons float gently in the air a
light breeze or a spark of static might send them drifting
unexpectedly be sure to tie them now securely yay new toy
wait to get back to the shelter alright didn't we open this
it's red I assume red equals no yeah new ramstick for my
little girl see I'm lost already i'm already lost any idea
what it does all right there's uh
okay um i would love to if there isn't a job oh my god okay
oh no
There we go.
It's over.
Oh, it's over.
Actually, I don't need a heal yet.
I don't remember how...
I don't remember.
Oh, is there nothing else here?
Was that it?
Oh, wait, there is stuff here.
Okay, the parkour.
Alright, performance test.
These limb replicators are convenient.
The massive influx of power, they require means they end up
bulky.
I'm going to try running one on a mobile power source.
mini handheld replicator using an eva suit as a battery and
i say it blow my nose and i say i say what dokey where the
what oh there it wait no it's empty oh fuck sorry i need my
nose oh there it is my nose is clogged i say
i say it was about 30 percent successful it was was pretty
handy but it guzzled electricity uh i take about four or
five batteries just to make a wall like this that defeats
the point of miniaturization in the first place some
mistakes are half the fun or discovery maybe i'm not mad at
material but i'm happier that way call it play around you
like else i'm doing what i love well thank you the super
chat thank you thank you uh i had to step out for a minute
has a child earned her second doctorate yet second doctorate
what is she Or something?
How dare you insult my child's intellect?
She is on her fifth doctorate, as she should be in our plan.
In her after all.
Let's use a chip to make a path.
I want to see the branches generate again.
Can't believe you insult her intelligence like this.
Alright.
Am I actually, I'm gonna re-bind.
I'm gonna re-bind the search thing.
Um, where the fuck is it?
Where is the scad?
There's an LimiRacer?
What is a LimiRacer?
Oh, wait.
Uh, I don't have a delete button, so it's gonna, I think
it's just gonna have to deal with that.
Confirm.
Oh.
I don't know.
Okay, there we go.
Oh, my God.
I don't have a delete button.
Unfortunately.
How do I delete this?
Let's turn that over here.
Okay.
I have an idea.
There we go.
I don't want it to be on C.
It's so inconvenient for me.
Oh, that's another...
That's another toy.
There we go.
Goodbye.
That's like five more than you, Toki.
Oh my god, it's a fucking win.
God damn it.
Every time.
Oh, new.
Sticky Bomb's dad.
the targets attach bombs temporary shrink the hacking mix
matrix and deal damage effects can stack number three okay
what oh all right i don't know if that's good though i don't
know we'll try it is there anybody here for me to use this
on There's so much stuff here.
This is why I don't like the tree level.
Alright, there should be something here.
How do I get in here?
Hello?
What the fuck do I get in here?
I can't even shoot the lock.
Alright, alright.
Okay, there's something that opens that particular door.
Guess I'll never know.
I'll never know.
I'm just so lost!
No, I was here before.
Oh, wait.
I haven't been here, though.
I swear to God, if that is a...
If that is a window, I swear to God, if that...
Okay, wait, wait.
Okay, it's not a window.
Alright, nice.
Okay, thank God.
It's not a window, guys.
It's real.
Stop skittering around.
Oh.
Here it comes.
Look out.
Alright.
Be careful.
Oh, fuck.
There's too many.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Decoy.
Okay.
Alright, I have to use the decoy.
Oh, my God.
Please.
Please shoot at each other more.
Look out.
all right nice nice try to me just kill him first oh this
was a trap this was a trap wasn't it are definitely a heal
oh but anyway how is this oh what's this oh it was a trap
fucking knew it how's the sound guys that sound okay so far
thank god for the decoy is there anything oh nice we
actually need all of that that's pretty good all right nice
let's get to know i'm using my glass pad right now i don't
know if i'm a fan of it i haven't used a glass pad in a
while but it's very smooth that's all i'll say is that it
that's it I fucking risked my life.
And all I got was, like, some bitties.
I'm just not used to how smooth it is.
The glass pad is, like, so if you're competitive, for those
who aren't competitive gamers, there's, like, several types
of competitive mouse pads out there that helps with
smoothing out your aim.
Glass pad, like I said, made of glass so you aim a lot
faster because it's a lot smoother the texture I usually use
fabric I usually use uh fabric uh pads um I can't wait to
see what it is and so there's a little texture to it um and
it's not as fast uh so I'm just testing out this glass pad
right now because like a lot of my friends use glass pad but
i'm not i don't i don't fuck with it i usually use the kian
uh game pad or mouse pad uh just because i like the top bit
of the fabric more um i think my dream is to have a my dream
is to have what's up okay all right dope my dream is to have
a lab for a mouse pad.
That's one of the collabs I want in one day.
It's like one of the collabs I have yet to get.
Just because I'm gaming.
There you go.
Like, I don't know where I've been and where I haven't been.
I'm so lost.
That's why I'm not a huge fan of this map.
All right, all right.
Sound is all right here.
All right.
Put it in the ram.
Eat the little ramstick.
Oh, wait.
Oh, guess not.
One more to go.
Oh, one more.
Let's wrap this up.
Oh, wait.
I'm going to go here.
I'm, like, so lost.
I'm so lost right now.
Everything looks the same.
I've been here.
Oh, shit.
Definitely not.
Oh, ha ha ha, what you gonna do now?
I got high ground.
That's right.
High ground control.
You almost got me.
No, I guess not.
When aren't you lost?
This is different.
There's trees here.
It's so different.
I can't shoot these.
Ow.
I didn't know the range.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I don't know the range.
All right.
At least I got your stupid toy.
This toy is modeled after an old sedan.
Sedan taxi.
A stellar break and turn through tiny streets with included
wireless controller.
This can be given to Diana.
Alright, now I can open this.
Things I do for my kids.
Oh my gosh, wait.
I might as well, like, go back this way.
Also, I need to... I need to heal a little bit.
I keep forgetting that Sprint doesn't require me to actually
use my energy.
That's why I haven't been sprinting on this much.
Because, like, the dash is only for my charge.
Oh, we used to use this.
Oh, wait, that's new.
Alright.
If this was Leon, he'd simply back flip over lasers, by the
way.
Terminator, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
oh she's not strong enough it's red she doesn't she hasn't
ate the ramstick for that yet right now where do i go can i
do this oh no where am i this is the entire game where am i
all right lord Oh, red key.
Nice.
But how do we get that?
It's an item I haven't gone yet.
Alright, open sesame.
Okay, reduce this defense.
Oh, if I come back.
Did I get everything in that area, though?
I don't know.
I can't tell I actually can't tell There's so many items I
have yet to reach Alright
There's stuff here
I'm so lost Wait Is there a ramstick over there There might
be a ramstick ramstick over there.
Maybe?
Dude, it's like all around me, but yet, like, there's so
many options but yet none at the same time.
Okay, I can.
I can either... I can play something here.
Yeah, I have three ramsticks.
Alright, and then another one.
just need to slot in one more chip okay oh oh of course
okay okay i don't know where the last ramstick is maybe no
that's where i want okay that's fine that's fine oh my god i
so happy when this area is over.
This is my filter.
This is, I'm slowly getting filtered.
I am very slowly getting filtered from this area.
It's okay.
Everything will be okay.
I don't know if I want to, I'm just gonna go up here.
I don't want to reset anything yet.
I'm just gonna hope that there's uh
All right, I have to reset it.
Yeah, I'm gonna...
I don't want to reset the enemies, but I might have to,
because I thought it would, like, go around a little.
Touch grass and get filthy.
I just don't like the level design for this one.
Like, the first two, I love it.
This one, I'm just not at first.
fan.
I'll just be honest.
I will grab.
Oh!
I'll just invest on my child.
I'll grab a little bit of HP.
Alright, units, dynamic.
I don't know if I like the sticky bomb thing, because I
don't have any problems with hacking so far.
Um...
we'll grab more damage for this all right what else should i
up oh critical shot you guys told me critical shot is really
good so i'll grab that uh oh do i have enough for more node
slots i do i just need a thousand i just wasted it all on
critical shot i'll save up for the other one you some toys
new toy yeah why is there nature in my dystopian paradise
paradise i said what i said
i want to drive it all right play with the toy i got you
there i spent a thousand dollars on it
Diana.
Play with the toy.
Why do I bother?
Why do I bother 3T printing this?
Oh.
Go.
It's like, whoa, cool.
Thank you for the new toy, daddy.
Anyway.
Oh my god, she's playing with it.
Oh, it's fine.
Never mind.
All is forgiven.
This is great.
Entertain.
There it goes.
I never doubted you for a second.
The branches just grew in from nowhere.
1k.
Well spent.
Alright.
Now you have balloons.
Ballons.
Just like what the fuck is that?
I was like when you're in space.
in the space.
It's like a chemical.
Yay!
Oh, and she plays with the balloons that cost like one
dollar.
Oh, okay, that's cute.
Come on, Mr. Balloon.
That's cute.
Oh, look at that.
Look at her go.
She likes her balloons.
I like the fucking car.
The
Yeah, it's like, I give a cat like this expensive tour, and
then she plays with the box.
Not a bad idea.
Not gonna lie.
A bunch of kids have already tried that.
Yeah, but are they a space kid?
Exactly.
You getting along okay with that janky box with the funny
dad.
They have a name, you know.
It's Cabin.
He's in a pod.
They're really nice.
Aww.
Little one.
They don't even call you by your name.
I don't think she...
Well, she...
I gave her that name, though.
Am I missing...
Oh, I'm missing one more.
I assume, like...
Like, it changes when I get everything.
I do am missing, like, a...
Oh, nice.
Nice.
If you're interested.
No, we didn't.
Oh, I need to find this area.
Mass production.
I'll find that later.
And she never finds it again.
Don't worry, guys.
I'll find it later.
Don't do not worry.
She never finds it.
It's a really cool machine that lets you do training
simulations.
No way.
She never comes back.
Oh?
She's excited about something.
Hey, Hugh, let's play.
Do you ever play any of those games that kids are into?
Like hide and seek?
What's that?
You hide, someone finds you, rinse and repeat.
I was a master at it.
Not a single person can find me.
Hugh, I want to play.
It just means no one cared enough.
hide and seek with her oh my god i'm gonna show her i'm
gonna show i'm the best hide and seeker wait i have to find
her where the fuck did she go
oh my god i'm timed oh i see her that's right oh she's like
the strap like if i don't see him then they don't he doesn't
see me you found me that's right You'll never be me at
hide-and-seek.
It's like those kids that hide behind the curtain.
He's like, they'll never find me.
And if I was like...
And if I was a weak parent, I'd be like, where is she?
But I'm not weak.
God, teach her how to win.
Must have unfulfilled slots?
Where?
Canyon.
I want to get this game.
Not because I want to be a father of the actual
responsibilities of having them.
Because it's just so fun.
Oh, they have a super chat.
They can think.
That's right.
Kids gotta learn.
I don't coddle weakness.
I'm here to build winners.
Now she'll try and improve the hiding.
Alright, let's go.
Yeah, I have to teach them the pain of losing.
So they'll never want to lose again.
Alright.
Hmm.
What?
Okay, I...
I was like, hmm.
I had a feeling.
Alright.
Let's give him a little shock, shall we?
I was like, hmm, I wonder why there's stuff below me.
Hoey!
Alright.
Alright, these defenses are down.
Oh wait, I have to hack him.
What?
How did I miss?
Oh no.
Oh no, if only I got that thing!
If only I got that thing that lets me bounce around!
Oh my god, not again.
I forgot about it.
Even though I just saw it
Oh, I did not.
Alright, fuck it There's no such thing as overkill
I should have might have maybe I should have used that in
the beginning of the fight There's no such thing as
overkill, guys.
Oh, what's this?
Oh, I should move that.
Alright.
Oh, fuck.
Man, I wish only I have an ability that lets me hack all of
them at once.
Oh.
If only that exists.
God damn it, not again!
I know it's here!
Every time!
I like see it too!
I see it, I let it happen!
Oh god.
Okay.
Alright.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
See, I told you.
Uh, riot blaster.
Well, grab riot blaster.
Since it's new.
Alright, heal again.
Oh my god, this room fucking sucks.
Why do we even need to rescue her?
What's she gonna do for me anyway?
I don't need another kid.
Already have Diana.
All right, Laura Tide.
Is everything sorted for
the study to enrich soil fertility with nitrogen oxide via
artificial lightning?
Think we have what it takes to knock the CEO socks off?
We've always known that benefits were there, but the current
model was just too cost prohibitive.
But if we use lightning generators made from them, we can
get positive results at a fraction of the price.
Sounds promising.
This might be what we need to get biomass back in the dead
zone.
Oh.
Oh, they're figuring out how to save the environment.
Yay.
Let's hope they don't get murdered.
It's a joke.
BI, it's a joke.
They all died of natural causes.
If anybody is listening, they all die to natural causes.
They are about to deteriorate.
Oh, nice.
We got the other last tip.
All right.
It's like how all the scientists were next to windows.
Let's see what's down here.
that regulator and go help eight yep on it all right oh nice
at the performance test range bots undergo lightning
resistance testing and this is high risk at test entry is
strictly prohibited for all unauthorized personnel reckless
entry may result a serious injury oh i don't want to be here
then i guess that deadly window oh what the why would they
oh all right just sitting here menacingly oh shit oh wait he
is also sitting there menacingly i'll just shock on him whoa
no more shotgun.
It should be five.
Alright.
I've been here.
Oh, wait.
I have been here.
This is like the first area.
See, this is also why I just don't know.
It all looks the same.
I already forgot this was the first area.
You all just blur it again, they prove me.
We had to go through all this for one regulator.
All right, we're gonna...
I need to go back and reset my heals.
That's fine.
As long as I don't drop down, it should be fine.
It is.
It is too much grass.
It is 100%.
You can't stay here for a while, right?
All right.
Do I have...
No.
I should have enough money right now.
Yeah.
node I really wanted to upgrade my nodes oh oh where's my
hacking nodes okay oh wait I never mind never mind oh I
guess it's for the confused wait do I have enough points for
that hacking no
All right, let's ride the tramp.
Yeah, I don't have any...
I got a print my shotgun and decoy.
All right.
Yeah, but I have no money.
I only have $100.
I spent it all on my child, on Diana.
She wanted balloons.
And now I have no life savings.
That is welcome to...
Welcome to being a parent.
Current, thank you to Super Chat.
Thank you.
I heard you're trying to go to chubby cattle.
As an L.A.
Goon, don't.
Overpriced.
And they all really?
But like, why is there a 90-minute wait for all three more
chubby cattle?
I don't understand.
They got him.
They got up.
They baited us all.
A FOMO.
Not FOMO enough for me.
I heard 90 minutes and I was like, fuck that shit.
If I'm gonna wait 90 minutes for food, I'll be in Japan.
Like...
Why do that with like...
Oh, no.
Alright, it's fine.
Oh, shit!
It was not fine.
It was...
Absolutely not quite.
Oh my god.
There has to be an easier way.
Oh
my god, it's this guy again.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Oh, no, I don't have any more charges.
What?
What's this?
Okay.
It's fine.
I could dash forever.
Whoa!
Nevermind.
Maybe not.
Alright, nice.
I actually need it.
Critical hit!
I know it's like standing a lot when I'm not in Japan.
Like...
Here it comes again!
Oh.
Now it's my turn.
Fuck, I didn't realize.
Alright, he's gotta keep shooting.
Whoop!
Get dodged!
Oh, fuck.
Whoops, sorry, sweetie.
I got too fast.
I'm trying!
He doesn't want to look at me!
It's alright.
I'm swearing in front of the child, but it's okay.
I'll just I'll just remove it from its hard drive That's the
best part of them having AI kids You make a mistake just
remove just delete it from the hard drive
How did that miss?
It said it would hit
Oh Oh Oh Goodbye
Oh, that's not fair.
He doesn't care about electricity.
I'll just double-tap it.
Whoa.
Excuse me.
Oh, my God.
Please stop.
I actually need it.
Are you seriously closed up just when I wanted to shoot it?
Oh, nice.
stand here.
I cannot stand here.
I cannot.
Please.
Oh, please.
That's not fair.
Okay.
Okay, it's fine.
Okay, I can't.
I'm trying.
Diana, please.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
It's fine.
All right, there we go.
There we go.
It's fine.
Now we can just chill.
Now we can chill.
I'm just reloading very, very slowly.
Oh, my God.
Please.
Oh, I can.
Okay, thank God.
Okay, I thought I had to be close to it.
Alright, one more, one more!
Are you fucking kidding me?
There you go.
Holy shit.
Fucking round two with this guy.
Slowly.
Oh, he got Thanos.
Doesn't feel so good no more.
whoops oh my god look at him he's disappearing he's resting
over oh wow a decoy gun oh bye that took a while to die if
oh if only I had those if only those guns printed a little
bit faster oh man that would have been been so useful.
That's over.
We still gotta reboot that regulator, Hugh.
Oh, yeah.
About that.
Let me go grab some stuff first.
Yeah, I was expecting some bot to go uga-buga-buga there.
To flank me right there.
Mistokia don't feel so good.
That really is.
guess so
is there anything else here
I'm gonna need that did I miss loot?
did I actually?
I don't know I don't see anything here
you sure?
the only thing I missed is that these are like other stuff
that I can't reach now I'm pretty sure I'm fine.
That's from another area that I cannot reach yet.
I'm just too stupid to figure it out.
It's one or the other.
It's hard to figure out which one is the right answer.
What's this?
Oh!
You're getting...
Nice!
I updated my hard drive to an SSD.
Let's go!
That one, like I have five terabyte of storage, guys.
Let's fucking go.
Okay.
Nice.
All the places to put this thing.
Anything else I'm missing here?
No.
I think the trees by the left are getting smaller.
Almost there.
Yay, deforestation!
There's still one more left.
I was still missing one more.
Oh, thank God.
I don't have to be here in that area.
again
all right the plant factory we're out of here diana that's
me you thought of it i see be careful diana
i like how like when you get close to the cat you're like do
not do i i always test these theories to be like do they
program this in they're like do not the cat like not even
like it's like five meters they give her like five meters to
like you cannot
tell me you got something oh fucking course
oh my god you kidding me
okay that's bullshit okay i need to get this out of here i
don't have like the multiple so it's so much more annoying
okay all right charge boom
oh my god i'm trying to jump boom
i'm gonna get him out of here
oh my god are you fucking kidding me You closed up now?
Alright, I got both of them.
Never mind, do not.
I did not get both of them.
Oh, no.
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh, I am so low.
HP right now.
Oh, my God.
I'm so not okay.
I am so not okay.
Woo!
I'm jumping!
There you go.
One HP in a dream right now.
Oh my god.
I have to reload.
Reload!
Oh.
I used to...
Oh, I just had no multiples.
If I had the multiple node, it would have been so much
easier.
It was just too much hacking.
Oh, there better be a safe point here.
Research on self-growing saplings is in progress beyond this
point.
As you know, the plant factory is developing plants that
continue to grow after printing, adapting naturally to
environment.
These saplings are extremely delicate, so contamination on
subjects must be avoided at all costs.
All visitors entering the clean room must pass through the
contamination room.
first decontamination cannot be skipped but you may choose
hide a room freely all right so we got to go through a or b
if we want to continue just pick one right oh wait let me i
said all right but it wasn't i but it was not all right oh
shit okay just pick one but the worst that could happen
where is a or b come on we'll know when we get there do i
though all right
evaluation are underway to identify the optimal
configuration of existing bots for fully automated
cultivation operation so two watchers and i don't even know
i don't i do not give them names walker mk okay walker mk
which one's easier i do not have a lot of hp left
remember what they are.
I...
Bots are bots.
We'll go with A.
This is A, right?
My child will not settle for less.
My child will settle for less than an A.
I am one HP with one gun.
Go back to the save first.
I should.
I don't know where the save is.
I want to, guys.
But where?
I'm so...
Yeah, but then I have to fucking fight this again.
Well, when you put it that way, how can I resist?
Oh, no.
It's back here.
I see it.
Oh, I have to fight those guys again.
I'll have the multiple nodes, so it'd be easier.
At least I'll have the...
I'll be able to print more nodes.
I found more filament for it.
I'm so healthy.
Oh, you want to do one more limb regulator?
The tree will disappear.
Oh, let's play hide and see.
Oh, you want to do again?
Well, find me this time.
Oh, I should build the Confuse.
You're right.
Where is she?
Where are you?
I was gonna say, what if she's hiding there again?
Wait, where is she, actually?
Wait a minute?
Wait a minute.
Oh, I see you.
That's right.
Wow.
You're so good at this.
That I'm right, I am.
I won't go easy on you just because you're a kid.
all right i'm gonna save up for that i finally get this one
though really fire damn it
that was a good one she looked like a balloon x rupees and
it reduces passing through multiple nodes all right oh yeah
because it'll do friendly fire um
I wonder why I upgrade.
I don't know if I want to print sticky bombs.
Because I'm going to save up.
I'm going to save up for stuff.
Okay, I need to...
Okay, this one needs to equip that.
Alright, hacking.
There you go.
Now I have stuff for it now.
Thank God.
Alright, off we go.
Oh,
a central lift.
All right.
Time to hack.
Time to go through that round two.
At least I'll get money for it, too.
Am I participating in the Marvel Rivals tournament?
I got asked to.
And I said I'd only do it if I wasn't captain.
Just because I don't... I just...
I just don't... I'm already stressed out, man.
So I don't know.
I don't know yet.
That was, like, the only thing I asked for.
I was just like, as long as I'm not captain.
So I don't know.
I haven't heard anything back yet.
I was like, I'm too stressed up.
I'm like, if I didn't have the concert, the Niki stuff, the
other stuff I'm working on, I'm pretty, I'm pretty.
I'm already alright
Just don't have time To be stressed To be even more stressed
out Alright That's fine
Oh my god I could have done the multi But I did it I didn't
do the multi again Could have
Alright.
That's right, you were 1 HP, but I didn't care.
Wait, what?
Oh.
Alright, let's go.
Headshot.
Oh, fuck, that was yours.
I thought that was mine.
all right nice i didn't get to you i still have a lot more
equipment this will turn the box apparently i use so many
notes i think like when i'm like hacking when i'm hacking
it's like oh i can't go back okay i'm sure both will have
stuff we can use i don't even have to read i only only only
go a no turning back now when there's so many nodes on my
screen i just went for which one the first one comes to my
mind.
Here it comes!
Look out!
What?
It's five.
Oh my god, I hate that.
It's over.
Sorry, it's over.
Like, I just see, I think it, I just see all yellow and I
just like, just get it all.
I don't even check like what nodes I'm activating.
It just flashes yellow and I'm like, all of it.
Like, I just want to hack it all.
Because I had no time to process.
I have to hack and shoot.
One of them is locked, huh?
Might be some good stuff in there.
If you're up for the challenge.
Oh, is it that one?
Yeah.
Fuck yeah, I am.
I don't coward.
Wonder what we can get for that at the shelter.
Okay, this is the red key card.
Oh, I'm in.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, I'm in.
I'm in, then.
Is this the right way?
Guess we'll find out.
Oh.
Grab.
Um.
Grab this.
Fuck it.
Alright.
Room one.
Here we go.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I guess here we actually go.
Oh, fuck.
There you go.
Nope.
Back off.
No, fuck these guys in particular though.
Fuck these guys.
No, I hate these guys.
I'm just gonna blow up these guys first.
Whoa!
There you go.
I don't want to waste my ammo just because I don't have a
lot.
Nice!
God, I hate those lasers.
There's a goddamn mini lasers.
Like, I have to play jump rope and fight for my life!
I can't shoot!
We did it!
Alright.
I don't have any decoys left.
It's like, yeah, I'm literally playing Fall Guys while
fighting for my life right now.
This place has got some useful stuff.
No, it's sort of a roguelite with the little printing stuff
with the...
Printing in each room.
Shockwave gun.
I don't really need it.
but fuck it it's it's there oh oh oh yeah what do you mean
what if only we had a unit to delete no if only
That's fine.
Where the fuck?
Oh, I guess it's like right here.
That's fine.
Look, his little eyeballs are out.
Whoops.
Oh.
That's fine.
Yay!
Alright, that wasn't as hard.
It was one.
one guy.
Oh, I just had to say that.
I just had to say it's only one guy.
I just had to be cocky.
Oh my god, that's so bullshit.
It's not over.
It's never over.
There you go.
Thank god, Alt.
Now it's over.
Oh.
See, guys, I knew saving my alt for Pragmata 2 was a good
idea.
Nice.
Oh, I got a lot of money now.
Yeah.
Oh, is that the floor?
Left over?
It was sent to them.
All right, training data.
Oh, no.
There's a broken cabin here.
Maybe that's their training simulation data.
Cheap shot.
Oh.
I feel like they're never behind them.
Planets inside the Terra Dome are monitored by dedicated
regulators in each area, which will automatically shut down
in the event of a problem.
After resolving the issue, reboot the check regulators can
be linked together but the system is offline each must be
restarted manually almost forgot about the limb regulator
then we take the lift to go see eight right yeah oh shit
that's a deer we can't even print deers now now we got deer
they look like family probably a buck in his phone so their
DNA is a 50% match well a family isn't just what's in your
DNA it isn't not at all i mean i was adopted adopted yeah
when a family takes you in as their own even though we don't
share the same dna that's foreshadowing i'm gonna adopt her
later all right we can go up the elevator now we can print
butterflies but we can't print yeah what's the point i get
everything i did new a new unit he's the use and capable of
fully automatic fire this rifle prioritized speed over power
hitting enemy weak points with slight increased heat buildup
ammo will replenish automatic oh
which i don't know he's using a fully automatic fire
Okay.
Will it be better, though?
Carbide.
You think this is better?
We're here.
The alfai sure didn't skimp on security.
Yay!
The trees are gone!
Oh!
Now let's get on that lift and go.
Oh, I guess the red room.
Nice.
Oh, the red room leads to the exit, too.
That's good.
But I can go here, too.
all right now i'm here rescue eight let me explore like wait
a minute you're not supposed to come from this side too late
i'm here now it's backtrack time
backtrack time oh wait this is where oh wait this is the
first area what the fuck wait i could just Wait a minute.
This was the first...
Wait, I could have just flew?
I could have just...
You mean I could have just flown over there this entire
time?
I didn't even have to do the red room.
Oh, it was closed with glass.
Oh, okay, that's a lot smarter.
I like how they have their own version of yellow paint with
the little money, the money trail.
Oh, nice.
I can give her grass.
Made it.
First few ever do, you stumbled upon the top secret Terra
Dome, Hanami Club.
Once the filament cherry trees reached perfection, we'll get
it here with our finest sake to celebrate.
Since you've discovered a hidden spot, consider yourself
invited.
Yes.
Another secret club.
That's a Japan thing, I think.
Hanami?
I love the little money trail they give me.
cherry tree having a good old time.
Whoa, that sounds like fun.
All right, let's go back, upgrade, and do the B room for
more money.
I need the loot.
My loot senses are tingling.
I crave the loot.
All right.
Can I?
No, I can't.
I keep forgetting there's no yellow blocks.
I guess I'll grab this now I feel like I have to at this
point I've been knocked down a little bit too much It's like
it's the worst too Because they like they like knock me down
But like they fucking they like chain me Which is worse
Upgrade the confusion So I need it now
What do we upgrade?
I don't know what to upgrade, guys.
For more damage?
Should we get damage here, or should we upgrade our guns?
What should we do?
What would be better?
Do we do CAC decode or...
Gun?
Cross?
No.
I mean, I guess I could just...
I'll just print it.
out give diana that wasn't our that wasn't in our options oh
double charge you're like here's a here's a fifth mysterious
surprise option
all right all right now we give diana flowers we rebooted
both the regulators all right
There you go.
It's so fun talking to you, Hugh.
Just a few seconds.
Huh?
She generated me another art.
More AI art.
You can tell it's AI because she has three fingers.
Aww.
And I wanted to give this to you so you'd remember.
cabin.
Maybe there's something in stock.
We could literally print your clothes, Hugh.
What the fuck are you talking about?
Oh, Mori.
I suck.
Guys, I need more tokens so I can generate more art with
Diana.
Alright, let's see.
Cat, play bingo with you.
We've expanded our ship.
I haven't.
I haven't I haven't found them yet.
If you're interested.
I haven't found that red room!
We don't need it.
We don't need to do the simulators right now.
I want to equip my stuff.
I like my current things right now too.
Let's grab the sticky bombs and the riot blaster.
Alright.
Let's go.
I need to clear the B room because I want to grab more loot.
I yearn for the loot.
Look, I'm just waiting until I'm so upgraded that when I go
to that third red room that I just sneeze on them and they
die.
Like it's not even, it won't even be a challenge.
At least they don't respond, thank God.
I'm trying to be...
efficient right now i was a curious one always getting up to
no good kept chasing anything that caught my eye ended up
lost half the time what did you chase one time i went after
a squirrel and totally face planted oh my god squirrels
haven't gotten extinct yet for animals too just like me yeah
well that's how i know it's dangerous when enemy heat gauges
fill it will be knocked down down enemies can be hit with a
critical shot from close range a shot or but graduate
creases if they are left alone all right
I hope they're not what the fuck
I'm like so confused where everything is not gonna lie
Leave the shooting to me.
Alright, nice.
Oh, that is a lot more unexpected.
There we go.
Nice.
That's a lot of enemies, though.
Harry, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi, Doki.
Yesterday was my birthday.
I wonder if I could get a happy birthday from my Oshi.
Also looking for the content.
Thank you for the super chat.
chat they can thank you of course happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you happy birthday dear harry happy
birthday to you yeah happy birthday we have a great birthday
yesterday god damn it no not again let's do this oh my god
stop Okay.
I'm getting lost in the sauce right now.
Alright, it's fine.
I just have too many guns!
There's just so many guns now!
The first world problems!
It's just all guns!
i'm so bad at using numbers to swap weapons it's like it's
like i could use it's easier when there's two but when
there's four i'm like we're what number what number are they
all the numbers are blurring together what number am i on
okay all
right just a lot i go i already went a so time to go to b
Oh, I saw one more decoy.
Oh, we'll grab that.
I don't need it, but we'll grab it just to be like, just to
let the printer have some fun, you know?
Jump, Q.
All right.
Oh, my God, I'm so confused.
There's so many things on my screen!
There you go.
There you
go.
That's five.
Whoa!
That's no longer five.
Now it's my turn.
That's five.
We don't need anything.
What?
Who did I hack?
There we go.
I don't need a jump.
Alright, I just need to...
Take this!
Nice.
Last guy.
Okay, I got recharged.
Recharged.
Reload.
Oh, both of his head is down
Oop It's over Alright, I have no more notes Let's go
Alright, I definitely need another gun Thank God Alright,
last room I made a lot of money Oh, fuck, okay Alright, oh
Oh, okay.
Just remember, it's not just him.
It's not just him.
Alright, that's fine.
He doesn't know where I am.
He's blind.
Nice.
Whoa!
That's fine.
I killed him.
Alright, I have to do the overdrive now.
Okay.
All right.
Like a sombrow.
All right, then.
Then mega hack.
Let's go.
Yay!
Done now.
Take this.
We did it.
So easy.
Okay, now I can refresh.
Actually, I think after you just go back to the shelter.
I don't need to print more stuff.
What does Sombra say when she ults?
I don't remember.
I don't place.
I've not seen a Sombra in so long.
Yeah, who needs resources when I could just hack the world?
You said that you were adopted, right?
It was the same area.
When I was young, I was in an orphanage.
Orphanage?
about your age when my parents took me in is that different
from a regular family i couldn't tell you what regular is
but they loved me all the same not alone was enough oh my
god i just see the translated it's just turning off the
lights i was like i don't think that's what somber says but
i realized that's just a propaganda let's loose i don't
remember how pretty what's the english line what's the
what's the what's the english line of that because i know
like when you're when you're like on your own team on your
own team she says it in english yeah i was just like do i
turning off the lights i'm pretty sure somber did not say
yeah that's what he translated on google
what was the english line Lights out.
Oh, yeah, okay.
That makes more sense.
All right, now I can fully max your out.
There you go.
My investment.
Yeah, the Google Translate was like, turning off the lights.
I was like, that does not sound right.
That's a bit too many words.
Is that the shotgun, right?
Yeah.
I like the shotgun.
Alright, EMP activated.
Yeah, yeah, there we go.
EMP activated.
That's what she says.
Alright, StasisNet.
I haven't seen a Sombra in so long.
That's why I legitimately forgot.
But yet she gets a lot of the skins.
It's like, don't understand about Overwatch.
They give all the MVPs to the supports.
but like you rarely ever get like it's a poor envy like it's
a miracle if you see a mercy play of the game it's like it's
it's a fucking miracle and like same as sombra she has so
many skins and mvps like like she can get play of the game
but you don't see her in rank as often anymore i mean if it
was old mercy yes where she just people that die on point i
have res then yeah but you barely see that shit anymore game
default all right let's go all right now we can save the
girl all right i will finally where is the red room that's
in new york city i remember that which room was it it was
like the shopping district right here Oh, there it is.
Alright, we'll finally do the bingo.
We'll finally unlock the bingo.
Alright, where the fuck is this?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, it's literally right here.
It's literally right here.
Oh.
I don't have any keys.
Never mind.
Guys, one day I'll come back.
back.
I don't even have the key.
Oops.
One day.
We'll return.
Alright, let's go.
Central lift.
No bingo for me.
Alright, let's see.
uh oh yeah this way oh god save the cat she's not a cat i'm
gonna be very disappointed but i know i'm i'm like setting
myself up for failure because i know she's not a cat i get i
have a feeling she's not a cat could she be the scientist
that made you i don't think so no it's not that i i just
feel like she's someone important to me damn i wish i have
the key for that too all right let's open this up am i glad
we found you i have a feeling she's not a cat guys this is a
key No.
Uh, starts a period where weapon damage.
I really need that.
Alright.
She's actually a dog.
Surprise!
I don't go this way.
Oh.
Fucking knew it.
It's never a cat.
I fucking knew it.
Anna, you're here.
I don't trust you.
I think...
Oh, wait.
There is a cat.
Oh, my God.
Wait, there is a cat.
So you're a...
A welcome surprise.
What on earth happened here?
While I was preparing to depart for earth, a moon quake
struck damaging Ediths.
A moon quake?
The gods, these trees, everything went out of control.
This game does surprise me.
The cat was real.
Oh my god.
Alright,
and now I'm a father.
If we can access the mainframe, we could force Ediths
offline with this stop code.
You know what?
A welcome replacement.
A child for my team.
power lies within you Diana huh and her like that in my
memory I see how unfortunate well let's see what we can do
about that tree well thank you for the raid then thank you I
got a good stream I'm sorry I have no help that's not true
You've made it this far, haven't you?
I did.
We can stop Edith's together.
I don't trust her.
It's too tempting to offer.
It sounds too easy.
We'll shut Edith's down, and then we'll head to Earth.
I don't know if I can trust her.
We'll get you out of there.
Like, why is she gripped by the trees?
You two look like twins.
Like...
What's up?
Like, how does a moonquake make it so the trees start
gripping her?
I'm sure why she wants to go to Earth.
It's all too suspicious.
That'll come after we bust her out.
Should be another regulator down below.
One that can clear that tree.
Yeah, like, what happened?
A moonquake doesn't just start gripping.
I don't know.
Everything is too suspicious.
here doesn't add up too many coincidences god damn more
trees i can hear the sound of waves what did we print water
what the fuck oh hey follow the money trail though how do i
follow the money trail wait i see the money I see it.
How do I?
I see the money trail.
We printed a goddamn beach.
Oh my god, I can't reach it.
There's like...
There must be a way to go up there.
I don't know how to get up there.
There's the money trail.
What can we not print?
We found the money algorithm.
We found the water algorithm.
Is that the sea?
Why exactly?
Why leave?
Why go?
Why go back to Earth where I could just print everything?
I have pretty eyelashes.
I don't believe.
There's no way.
You've been to the sea before?
Wait, this is a hologram?
Got a house with a view and everything.
But it's not real.
Nothing is real.
We'd head down to the water anytime we felt like taking a
break from it all.
Nothing is real on the moon.
Ocean breeze does a number on the paint.
I guess they have this so that people won't go crazy from
moon sickness.
It'll make sense when you see it.
You know, back on earth.
Damn, he's rich.
He has a house.
you're just gonna stay yeah from moon fever what do you want
I want to go to earth I really go the government's just
gonna take her away then I can go see your house and the
ocean and real trees you bet oh we let her home I feel like
the moment we enter Earth's atmosphere, the government's
just going to take her away.
And then, we can all go to Earth together.
Yeah.
There's no way we're allowed to have a multi-billion dollar
AI living in my house.
Let her believe, Doki.
Aren't you a kill?
Doki's such a dumber.
Imagine how many taxpayers' money went into developing her.
And they're like, she's just going to live in this man's
house.
He ain't waiting.
No daughter's allowed on earth.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, where am I?
Why did I get here?
Oh.
Oh, this place is pretty dark.
All right, more training data.
All sectors of the Terra Dome remain fully operational and
construction of near-air is proceeding on schedule.
Over team tasks now handled by bots, human-caused delays
have been eliminated.
Smooth selling, system inspections noted on unrecognized
admin level updates to ETHS.
Possibly authorized by Earth HQ?
I'll follow up and then...
Oh.
Oh, that's for a chat.
Somebody chinkers.
with edis is that even possible i bet there's a bunch of
security well like anyone could get past all that someone
tinkered with it either that or edis edis like uh tinkered
like figure it up broke the programming and fixed himself
Lord, I don't know if we could just run up to the water.
No, it's not even real.
I can't even drown in this
Can't it's fake water I can't even drown in this and it
won't let me
There's like obviously something there, but I knew it I knew
it was parkourable
Hacker god damn is this glass I I fucking knew it.
It's always glass.
I don't need to grab this.
Alright.
Botan, wait, oh my gosh, how many weapons are there?
Mobility is reduced, but damage increases the longer the
beam is sustained.
Oh!
Oh, it's a Zarya beam!
Okay, try the photon laser.
Oh, where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, shit.
Actually,
there you go.
Okay.
All right.
There you go.
Oh, there is.
There's one.
Oh, it's all locked.
There's so many weapons now.
I didn't even know I was supposed to unlock some.
I just skipped that.
Look out for targeting guys.
Yeah, let's do this.
All right.
Oh, oh, oh, he's invisible.
Oh, oh, oh.
One bullet's bounced right off.
What did I...
What is this?
There we go.
It's like, excuse me.
What are you?
Why are you invisible?
Oh, fuck.
Okay, he's not opening up again.
Hello, please.
open up, sir.
Oh, nice, he's dead.
Yeah, I was gonna say, like, do I just shoot it?
What do I do?
It's invisible.
A little spooky.
Oh, I'll just beam it.
Oh my god, not again.
There you go.
Look at us for a targeting sensor.
Goodbye.
Is there any extra loot?
Huh.
That goes all the way down.
Do I go all the way down?
Oh!
Yeah!
Alright, we'll go this way.
Down I go.
Oh no, money, money.
Keep that laser shooting for continuous damage.
Where am I?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, no.
You gotta be kidding me.
That's cheating.
Thanks.
That's fucking cheating.
that's right off wait what where
the fuck is this oh that's where it's oh okay bye he was in
the dark got him grab this god fucking damn it that's two
the hardest hack of my life right maybe we should hire our
own bot to do this for us wasn't a dark he only got me
because it was nighttime he cheated i demand a recount
it's supposed to go okay that's a glass God, it's so dark in
here.
Okay.
Alright, one more.
Oh, okay.
It's literally right there.
Oh, that's convenient.
It's just one, guys.
I'm not that scared.
Alright.
Goodbye.
Oh, never mind.
It wasn't just one guy.
Eh, still sort of just one guy.
Now it's one guy.
I'll just slowly back away until we're hackable.
There you go.
Alright, now there's no guys.
No.
We'll keep this.
God!
Fucking...
Where did he go?
What?
Oh, there you are.
That's fucking right.
I see you.
I don't remember where his weak points are.
Oh, it's not.
It doesn't show up.
Okay, there it is.
How the fuck?
How am I supposed to shoot that?
No, you're not.
I can't hide if I'm fucking...
Where are you?
Wait, wait.
Wait.
Oh my god, he got me.
There you go.
We did it.
Alright, now we can hack.
There's nothing else here.
I don't know where that weak point is.
Weak point is in such a weird area.
That's all of them.
Let's keep up the pace.
Yeah, that should be everything.
I feel like I was missing one time.
No.
No, I wasn't.
To safeguard sudden experiments conducted in the Terra Dome,
we're testing systems that use high-tech jamming devices to
block outside radio interference.
The jamming signal blocks incoming interference for a
limited time.
preventing not only unauthorized access but also forced
intrusions like hacking please note that wireless devices
will also be disabled so exercise caution while activating
the system all right can't forget you all right we can go
back and upgrade the thing is the fucking spider bot if his
weakness is on the back it's so hard because they're never
like it's so hard to like have them turn around because
they're like i gotta kill this person in front of me why
would i ever turn around the sea was so pretty it was but it
wasn't real i couldn't believe my eyes like they're never
gonna turn my back on me they're not stupid that hologram
back there was pretty good but the real thing's gonna blow
you away even touch water i'll take you all over like i was
like is that is she waterproof i'm a little worried you i
don't think she's waterproof oh there it is you would have i
don't know it doesn't really seem like it all right we got
the gun oh yeah she's gonna sink i don't think she can float
no you're right i don't think she can float guys she's
literally i won't be surprised if she's oh to be fair i can
carry her so like she's not that heavy oh we'll grab the
code i'll upgrade photon laser
I'm sorry, I still don't have a red key.
I'm sorry.
Of this and this.
All right, printed new stuff.
Let's go.
All right.
That bingo is collecting this.
I don't have a red key.
I'm sorry.
I don't know where to find one.
I thought it was Luke gobbling very well too.
Alright.
Does she even know how to swim?
She's AI.
I could just Google.
I could literally connect her to Google.
And then she'll be fine.
What the fuck is that?
Oh, that's what it is.
What am I supposed to do?
What am I supposed to do with this?
Oh, I see.
Well, can't hack me if I'm up here.
Wait, what if I just stand up here?
Wait, I have an idea.
There we go.
I just stand on high ground.
I'll grab this too.
Oh no, which way is the right way and which way is bonus?
This is bonus.
All right, uh, all right we go this way.
What's this?
No, it's nothing.
It's just decorations.
Looks like that door's blocked.
Yeah, that tree's in our way.
I swear to God, there's an invisible fucker.
I swear to God.
I'm watching you.
There's a guy behind me, isn't there?
Why is your boss music?
I fucking knew it.
I fucking knew it!
I knew you were around!
God damn knew it!
You can't pull the shells right off!
I was like, why is your boss music?
Where is that coming from, huh?
That's right.
Foyled by the music.
I think that solves a little tree problem.
I'm behind you, aren't I?
She'll never know.
Seems like it only got rid of the trees in here.
all right that riot blaster is coming clutch
yeah thank god for music
oh there it is oh there it is
oh that's not good for me
whoop jammed actually i could Fuck yeah, I can just hack
this now.
Oh, never mind.
Give me a sec.
Oh, my fucking god.
Good job, kid.
It's fine.
I got it before he could do anything.
You know what, fuck this?
You get the decoy, and then...
Alright, there you go.
There we go.
Alright.
Get it all!
Alright, don't worry, I can hack soon?
Yeah!
There we go.
Oh, let me just grab this.
Easy!
Got more company.
What?
Oh, fuck.
Okay, that's fine.
Oh, it's just one little guy.
How you like this?
Oh!
Shoot out!
Watch out!
There's more!
there's more careful i know what you mean it's just what oh
my god it's one very fast guy there we go i was like what do
you mean there's more i i literally see the two guys diana
don't do this to me if we both can see where how many people
there are but wait there is some more
the stasis net i'm like diana please don't do this to me
uh oh thank you
oh nice oh what is that oh it's for the upgrade my it's my
thingy i was like there's no way there's more can i go
through that is there like a hidden wall back here like they
can't do this to me i must be able to get down from there
somehow yeah i was like you can't just show me stuff here
and be like no no no can't touch it no no
and then we actually need that all right lore i heard you're
transferring over to the limb lab lore tab that's right but
i'm a little worried why is that yeah Basically
immunological research?
I'm happy about the reassignment, but I'm worried I might
struggle to keep up.
Oh, is that with Dr. Higgins?
I've memorized all the papers, but some of the stuff he
comes up with on the fly.
I wouldn't worry too much.
You're not the first researcher to have trouble keeping up
with the good doctor.
Dr. Higgins is a very special man.
Just try to go into it, ready to learn.
all right i don't understand that conversation with the look
on how it adds to the lore
where we're gonna go there's already updated nearby let's
take it back to the shelter i knew it i knew there was an
entrance here we got a security zone how many mouse traps
are they gonna set for us
what oh okay i was gonna say oh they thought they got me but
i looked up
yeah oh oh i got playground oh it's like winnie the poo
thing i can't wait to get back to the shelter why don't i
get that oh like that there we go
all right now I can do that area.
That's right, guys.
I looked up.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Oh, they're giving me so many guns.
Shame is there something below me.
Alright, maybe I can just skip all that.
No!
Oh, God.
Enough already.
I can't just skip all that who would have thought oh my god
i don't even know where the jam is where the fuck is such oh
my god it's over here there
you go right on we got it just in time
fight fight
all right i'm just hoping they'll fight each other that's
good that's good fight each other
check take this all right yeah i don't like the jam mechanic
i know they're like oh it's a new mechanic but it's also
very scary
should be it oh nope oh nope to be called for more jammers
there you go i just got it though
are you fucking kidding me there's two there were two
jammers
Oh It was the two jammers.
I just fucked up Ah fuck it.
You know what?
These guys are big boys
This is my turn Do you do that
Oh my god, there's They have so much HP.
It's just all HP.
It's going to jump.
Whoops.
There, that should kill him, right?
Nope.
Oh, my God.
I did not mean to do that.
Okay, thank God there's a critical.
Take this.
They're so tanky.
don't have like more guns I use oh wait there is unless I
was gonna say I thought 3b 3d printed everything that's good
I just shoot that okay that did a lot of damage which is
nice oh we need more 3d printers like
i for the nodes i don't hacking is not that hard it's just
they're just so tanky
there you go nice finally a critical node die zero hits
might be upgrading their designs zero damage at least at
least they're printing out guns while doing this thank god i
make it to the other side
oh i guess that's out
nice yeah
i will say my criticisms that some of the bots are just way
too tanky i just like not as enjoyable when they're like i
guess like maybe i just need to upgrade in more But, like,
it's just a bit annoying.
I feel like I'm doing nothing, you know?
I'm, like, doing, like, tickle damage.
They're a robot, Stokie.
Yeah, but they could use cheaper metal, you know?
It doesn't stop them from using cheaper metal.
Who's funding them all these metals?
Oh.
Just here.
I hate quality printed filament.
Our tax money.
Okay.
I didn't even need to scan that and you instantly there was
something there.
Something above me too.
Okay.
Excuse me?
I swear to God, that is a window.
That's a fucking... I fucking knew it.
I'm like, there's no...
There's no way.
No.
Unless it's not a window.
Unless I'm gaslighting myself.
Is that window?
I can't tell.
There's no way.
That is not a window.
That... I can't tell!
I can't tell!
What if it's not a window?
Okay, it's a window.
Guys, it's a window, guys.
I go down or up?
And we'll go here first.
We're conducting tests with the newly developed filament
plants to determine whether natural cycles can proceed
without interruption.
Until the eco-modeling lab and the plant factory achieved
certain research milestones, the facility will remain on
standby In the meantime, we continue to simulate future
layouts, blending conventional Luna filament plants with
holograms, testing how the ecosystem will thrive once full
operation begins.
This section is so long.
I just noticed that.
Compared to the other two levels I was in, this is one of
the longer ones.
I wonder if the other ones are the area after this is long.
It sucks because this is the one I hate the most.
I am a hater of this particular level.
Can't forget you!
Alright.
I gotta go back.
Sometimes I just don't want to touch grass.
It's just too much grass.
I am an activator.
Yeah.
All
the...
Oh, there's more of the figures now.
Alright, more gun.
I can spare it.
An HP defense.
Um...
Fuck.
Why do I want to upgrade?
I'm gonna upgrade.
I think the laser was good.
I really like the laser a lot.
um grab a riot blaster it's been good to me what is sticky
bomb sticky bomb has worked out oh yeah we got new we got a
little swing for you diana who do your little swing that's
right you have you ever played on one of these Yeah.
Back then, when trees still existed on Earth.
Aw, wait, can I push her?
Aw, okay, I should be allowed to push her.
Does Capcom not trust me?
Aw, look at her.
Yeah, I like the laser a lot.
Hey, can I jump off this thing?
Yeah, do it.
Don't worry, your titanium legs will save you.
And higher.
Yay!
She played on the swing longer than my basketball court.
I'm just saying.
I'm not hate or anything.
I'm not mad or anything.
I'm just saying.
It's funny that she played on it longer.
Yeah.
She, I'm not holding a grudge or anything about it.
The saying is, it's funny that she played on that longer.
What the fuck?
How am I missing so many things here?
45%?
That swing reminds me of the Winnie the Pooh level in
Kingdom Hearts.
And I told the story before, But when I first played Kingdom
Hearts for the Winnie the Pooh level, I thought it was,
like, the other worlds where you had to complete it.
So I spent, like, days on the Winnie the Pooh level because
I thought I was supposed to complete it.
Like, I was like, how do I...
How do I unlock the key, the heart?
I was so fucking frustrated because I did not understand.
Yeah, because I was like, how the fuck do I progress?
Because I didn't have all the pages yet either for that area
But I kept like brute force.
I didn't understand that I had to get all the pages to
actually complete the goddamn level
It's that black stuff from before what it's the black stuff.
Oh, this oh this way more than what we saw toxic filament
You think the quakes cause this the makeup of this stuff is
all wrong?
It's not filament?
Like it's corrupted or something?
Must have been working on something special down here.
Yeah, what are they working on?
The planned Terra Dome 2 facility on the Lunar Service has
been indefinitely to postpone to prioritize emergency work
on the Nexus Tower and AI managed sectors.
We sincerely apologize for delivering this news and writing
deeply appreciated time, effort, and support.
You contributed.
Oh my god, I forgot to say.
they did send me the pragmatic creator package that
everyone's posting about with the the whole like electronic
box like the whole like powered box thing that contained the
package i got one too the reason why i didn't post it was
because i had to charge the box and i couldn't be bothered
I was you know I was very tired and stressed out I couldn't
I had it was like a charger and I was just like I'll do that
later and I mean I I never did it I like I was like other
creators must have received this box so that I just googled
like I just searched it up on Twitter just to see what it
like um because you have to charge it to unlock the box and
then i was like i'm just gonna am i gonna die here oh what
the fuck that's a hole i do i jump in i was just like i'm so
busy i'm so busy right now open this later okay i do have to
go down here and then i was just like i'm just gonna see
what the other content creators uh what it looks like on the
content creator channel I think I'm gonna die oh wait it's
cutscene okay it's scripted why does the box need charging
because it's like a it's like an electronic box it's like a
battery-powered box thing that holds the package because
it's like sci-fi but that's what we're here for you have to
charge it to open it.
And then, um, I was just like, but the box is in another box
in another box.
So, like, I had to open the exterior box and it was very
hard to open.
And I was just like, your presence here is a violation of
creators.
I'll do it later.
But I want to see what other creators what, what's inside.
Oh, it's a boss butt.
Oh, he just doesn't like it that we're here.
Oh, no, it's a spider butt.
oh my god that means i'm almost close to getting out of this
god-forsaken level i'm i'm almost oh it's a skull i do not
like that i do not like that oh my god is that thing from
poppy's playtime
i really appreciate capcom for sending it to me i'm just
sorry that I didn't open it yet.
Oh,
shit.
That's what he meant.
How is that not hitting him?
What the fuck?
I opened this.
Oh, shit.
There we go.
Oh, fuck.
I went too fast.
Come on.
That was a dodge.
What the fuck?
No way.
Okay, there you
go.
There you go.
How you like this?
Oh my god, I have to like stop it when I...
Serious?
Oh my, come on.
Okay, okay, I dodged it just in time.
he has so much hp oh i have it's so hard to balance all of
that but that's good
all right i actually need to go grab somewhere
oh no fuck okay that's five oh that is not five where is he
there's mines oh there it is
are you kidding me are you
okay give me a sec because all right there we go there we go
Alright, he's gonna drop down now, right?
Fuck this.
Get overdrive protocol, initiate.
Just overdrive this.
Fuck this.
There you go.
This should work.
Bitch.
Oh my god, oh my god!
Oh dodge!
Are you fucking kidding me?
Get me out of here!
Oh Scott dodged
Okay I should be allowed to do Where the fuck Whoa
Oh my god kidding me It's fine I have heals
Oh guys That's fine It's fine
There you go this is scary this is actually scary oh no no
oh my god you kidding me oh this one's so hard oh fuck okay
oh this one's hard oh i'm limping it's gonna go great next
time Oh, I don't have any more heals.
I used it all up.
Uh, I'm gonna go damage.
Oh, fuck, okay.
Maybe I should... No, I don't need to upgrade.
Oh, did I have one more?
Oh, I didn't see.
I thought I ran up.
Get that Stasis net out of here.
all right i'm ready i'm locked in i'm locking in oh oh all
right oh the last one got canceled i was so fucking tunneled
in i was like tunnel visioning in that one i didn't even
realize i thought i hit it it's way faster than it looks you
saw it kind of jump and then all those attacks talking about
its tail thing right yeah where is he
jesus christ leave the shooting to me
okay all right nice There we go.
Fuck.
There we go.
Watch out for his tail.
Whoa!
Dodge.
Okay.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay, that's fine.
Is he gonna beam it for now?
I'm trying to!
I swear to God, I'm trying!
Oh my god!
His tail is so annoying.
Alright.
There we go.
That's fine, you don't have to!
Yep!
I'm just gonna have to run.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine!
It's up on the pillars!
Oh, not the pillars, not the goddamn pillars!
I'm watching as much as I can!
Oh my god, dodged.
I can still hit it.
That's good.
Oh, nice.
I didn't know that.
That's fucking great.
I wish I knew that
All right
Oh, I got another gun I got stupid stasis net
all right oh i missed the crit no i can't help it there's so
many things going on in my fucking stream.
Yes, it's bugger.
Woo!
That's fine.
Oh my god, that's no longer fine.
Are you kidding me?
That took so much...
Oh my god, that took so much of my heals.
That's actually bullshit.
Oh my god.
Oh Okay
That still hits me No, no, no, no Drew I jumping
Oh, fuck I jumped I tied the wrong That tail- that tail is
so annoying.
I hate that tail so much.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Oh, that tail is OP.
I'm gonna actually have to do this.
I'm gonna actually grab mats.
Please have a gander.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna have- I need to get rid of the shotgun for sure.
The tail, the tail fucks with me so much.
Yeah.
Oh my god, this is so bullshit.
Like a cat go faster than what is given to me.
Ah!
Alright, we gotta retry it.
This is bullshit.
Okay, I have to wait for this.
No, no.
Oh, my God, that's close.
Oh, no, we have one more.
Come on.
Get me out of here.
No.
Get me that.
Oh, no.
No!
Oh, my God, we were so close.
We were so close.
Fuck this.
I'm fucking fighting the boss.
I'm like...
I'm so bad at parkour.
Wait, okay, I can fight enemies.
Enemies I can do.
Damn it.
It was right there.
It's okay.
I can fight things.
I know how to fight.
I'm a fighter.
I'm a fighter, not a parkour.
It's just not...
What do you mean?
It is weak.
Oh my god.
Don't skittering around.
Missile spotted.
Wait a minute.
Oh god, this is bad, actually.
It's fine.
Reloading.
Oh god, this is bad.
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god!
I have no ammo!
What do you want me?
I didn't do!
There we go.
Woo!
Get some!
Alright.
I'm not gonna get the final combo.
It's fine.
We might not get all the combo, but like, it's fine.
Alright, baby down.
down all right oh fuck this i'm just gonna fight the boss
fuck i don't need to fuck this i'm just i'm just gonna go
straight to the way i might be able to afford something here
i i can i can't afford anything it's fine it's fine all
right we gotta get the charge piercer Photon, decoy, okay,
riot blaster.
I don't like the Stasis net.
What the fuck?
There we go.
I didn't realize I spent all my nodes, the lightning nodes.
Uh, I didn't realize I spent all my light.
Oh, I should grab the, I'm going to grab the pistol.
Maybe the pistol will be better against him.
All right, here we go.
I'm locking in.
I'm locking in for real this time.
I'm locking in for real.
We gotta watch how the garden keeper moves.
It's dangerous.
It's his tail.
It's the fucking tail.
I don't know how to explain it.
But the tail.
It's the goddamn tail.
I know!
That's what I'm saying!
It's the fuck!
God damn it!
I know!
Be careful!
It's the goddamn...
Okay.
Are you kidding me?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god.
I hate this tail.
Okay.
I hate this tail so much.
Oh my god.
God, are you kidding me?
I can't, I can't.
Get him out of that pillar.
Get him out of there!
the stupid fucking tail
the goddamn tail
oh my god did not mean to do that I actually did not mean to
do that
be careful oh my god
let's do this oh my god get over here oh my god the critical
thank god the first critical in my life
are you kidding me are you kidding me that should be illegal
oh how
you like this i swear to god no no
oh oh my god
oh my god oh my god Not even close.
Not even close.
Easiest boss fight of my life.
So easy.
So fucking easy.
Just a little flesh wound.
Of all the boss fights.
This was definitely the easiest.
The first try.
It's a goddamn tale every time.
You're right.
It needs that boss fight needs to be a bit harder.
I feel like I need a real challenge.
Now we can go help eat.
Yep.
Let's go.
Yay.
What?
We did it.
It ungrifted.
I can finally move again.
We did it.
Thank you.
Are you okay?
No.
Well,
then there really is no more time to spare.
I must stop Edis.
Hello.
This is Edis.
I have detected an unexpected loss of biomaterial.
Oh, who could have done that?
I will be sealing this area indefinitely.
Oh, my God.
So rude.
You gotta be kidding me.
It's trying to trap us.
Oh, that's not good.
Why did you do anything?
Diana, give me your hand.
What the fuck?
I entrust this memory to you.
With it, you will learn how to stop Edith.
Are next to each other.
Take it and finish the task I started.
Hey, what are you doing?
We gotta move.
Oh my gosh, she's hacking me.
Oh, I don't trust her.
Her eyes are red.
This is a trap.
Oh, I don't trust her.
We're leaving.
Why are her eyes red and my eyes are blue?
A trap.
Yeah, she air drops me the files.
I'm pretty sure she just gave me malware, right?
Yeah, but the red eye and my blue eye counteract each other.
Oh my god, it's critical.
Oh, thank god, okay.
Alright, now we open...
Oh, thank god we're out of that area.
Fuck that area.
Okay, well now we go outside.
Hey, they're like, hey, can you check out...
I'm making this new game right now.
Can you, like, download this file and help me and, like,
playtest it for me?
Shelter license key, authenticated.
New functions have been added to the cabin system.
I feel like A is evil.
I don't know.
Everything just seems weird with her.
Yay!
Now online and ready to serve.
I don't trust you at all.
Edis' mainframe is at the mines, right?
Yeah, I think so.
Alright.
Yo-yes can now be printed and upgraded.
Hacking.
Hacking note that makes...
Turns out that deals more damage than exposed.
Gunfire increased damage on...
Which one, which is better, chat?
Strike mode, offense mode, or combust mode?
Definitely gonna grab the heat, though.
I need more nodes, anyway.
Combust is super fun.
While active weapons build, real use reduces.
Oh, wow.
He's burning up.
I like combust.
that then the combust modes do no damage seems good on paper
okay I mean it seems good on real life guys I don't want
good on paper I need good on util I saw you get the pass
okay we'll try it out then like I don't trust on paper I
need good on use okay we'll try that then it's about fun
we've procured a new staff oh man i wish i oh wait i have
this oh i have this all right nice oh my god i didn't
realize i could just activate this the entire time oh it's
lord i forgot about board number too you can scan secret
reports here oh wait there's a red key i now realize there
was another tab i mean cartridge holder is always good nice
more hp impeccable choice uh wait that looks like halo grab
bingo right now we are honored to provide Bingo!
Bingo!
Oh, I'm nine.
Lord, enemy making the next hack deal critical damage and
more easily oh, okay.
More nodes always good.
I'll grab another red key just in case.
We are honored to provide one of our greatest goods.
Alright.
We'll grab a here we are honored to provide one of our
greatest goblins bingo oh it didn't matter all right I spy I
don't care about another bingo we left eight all we promised
her that we put an end to eat us no time to mope we gotta
get moving yeah We'll stop Edith and rescue Aiden no matter
what.
Yay!
I mean, Aiden's inside her now, so we already rescued her.
You think about it.
Alright, now we'll go back to that area.
Alright, now we...
Should we have... Okay, we don't have anything here.
Oh, Decoy!
Get that Stasis net out of here.
Get that junk out of here.
Okay, we want...
shockwave gun all right now we have was it heat i want to
try heat defense and we want exposed or multi-hack i feel
like multi-hack has been good to us all right combust mode
time we hit those all right let's go for the red earth let's
finally open that door it's been 20 years but let's open
that door it's like here
That red door has been looking at us for a very long time.
It's finally time.
Oh my god, Toki is finally backtracking.
I'm doing it for the door.
Okay.
Should open up soon, right?
Oh, there he is.
There's him, though, right?
Yay, surely that's it.
Right?
Oh, there they are.
Look at how far it's targeting monsters.
Careful, they're hot.
Oops.
Get ready.
Oh, there's so many things on my screen.
I don't know what's going on.
There we go.
Nice.
Dead.
Oh, is that it?
Oh, fuck.
Alright, it wasn't it.
Jumped you.
There we go.
Wait, where am I?
What gun do I have?
There we go.
Easy.
Alright, now...
Now is the last one.
Eh, I had six bullets in there.
Why is that?
Oh, it's just another decoy.
Alright, open sesame.
Oh.
not a lot of items in this red room and by not a lot like
one item I mean that was an easy room too
the combust a little confused I will admit
I don't think I understood it I don't think I actually
understood what i was doing uh i just new training sim data
all right now i can unlock this
triple bingo i tried your congratulations yay
what's this oh it's the thunder one i finally unlocked it
self-defense response this is one of our more popular items
wait what does it do
i don't think we really need it do a girl grab bingo
and impeccable choice triple bingo congratulations yay the
bingo go to unlock what's that Deployed drones with
automatically attack.
Wait, this is better than decoy.
I'm my little buddies now.
Doki is a father now.
I'm a good dad.
You have quite the eye organ.
Okay.
I definitely need more nodes, though.
I'm like...
Who you guys all of this?
Alright.
Close quarters, relay it.
Fuck, okay.
Apparently freeze is good.
Heat as well.
And then...
I guess multi-hack.
I feel like multi-hack would be, would go well.
Okay.
Shockwave.
Change at the photon.
Plus for hit build.
I think that's good.
There's too much stuff to do.
There's so many builds now.
To the mines we go.
Alright.
How?
Guys.
I'm 50%, right?
I'm 50% through the game right now.
Because there's five areas.
And I'm on arena four.
Next.
up is the mainframe, right?
Yep.
It should be in the Nexus Tower.
I should be at 50% now.
I got out of the tree level.
Access near the Nexus Tower is restricted to authorized
personnel.
I'm authorized personnel.
Alright.
Oh.
Jump's extended.
User over is also slightly slower.
If I'm slower, he's also slower.
Also, yeah, what did 9 tell?
8 tell her.
We didn't even know.
9.
Okay, it was 8.
I can see the Nexus Tower.
So that's where Edith is.
Oh, no.
I wish we had a shuttle or something.
This is more open than the other.
I'm really, really bad with, like, levels I will say that
especially when there's no map any idea what it does the
towers right there why we gotta take the long way around I
don't know I just I see all what okay that's a spacesuit
things sure feel different when the gravity shifts how is it
different I'm so confused my thrusters pushes farther but
seems like an upgrade to me I'm just bad with like what's it
called when like open area?
There's a word for it I bet we could use those platforms to
get across use your thrusters and see if you can make it oh
fuck okay ah fuck okay there's stuff here open world games
yeah I'm very bad with them doing my part all right
equilibrium all right that is not true i'm good at when it's
enclosed i know where to go when it's linear because there's
only one way
I'm not fucking this up
What how am I fucking this
Okay Oh my god I just had to have her Um excuse me she was
like make sure to use your thrusters Like I was just
listening to instructions From my daughter Who I guess was
wrong the entire time Alright attack unit of fire is
powerful homer missiles it's a multi-target capability and
make it deal for crowd control but
all right so this is the no aim gun oh well i can hit
multiple people which is nice or is this multiple bots or is
this multiple bots that you speak of no idea my thrusters
cut it let's look for another way oh I see him I'm just
gonna shoot him right now just ready to get over here so I
can hack him come on little guy
come on I just don't want to fight him down here I'm just
gonna assume you know, he'll die eventually, right?
My hack doesn't go that far.
How about him?
Scary son of a tough old bugger He's just as lost as you Did
he seize me yet?
Oh, there we go There you go, he sees me now
There we go see it wasn't that hard Where's the other guy?
Where's the other guy?
He's hiding!
I like how he's hiding, he's like She's gone, right?
She's gone You think he'll finally turn around?
You scary Sullivan Good job kid
all right nice i should be all of them oh whoops whoops
whoops what the fuck oh oh i wasn't i wasn't paying
attention as always there we go okay it's all right she's
having hp
makes perfect.
It worked, eventually.
Just took a couple of tries.
We can use this to stop bots in their tracks.
I don't want to grab these.
Much better.
Eh.
Alright.
Nice upgrade.
I said sorry.
Sorry.
Should be everything, right?
Yeah.
I really don't want to backtrack right now.
I didn't realize there could be an area more confusing than
trees.
Okay.
unauthorized presence detected in the mining zone lunedigger
halt mining protocol and remove these intruders oh
something's coming oh no what the fuck what the fuck what
the fuck is that what the fuck is that oh there's always a
fucking space worm whenever we're on the moon There's always
a space worth.
No matter where we go.
Can we get rid of this stuff?
No.
At least not yet.
All right, we need to feed her some more ram.
Oh.
Get ready.
Wait.
Brode!
Am I doing it?
I don't know, man.
Stay awake.
I think I launched it I don't even know how much damage I'm
doing honestly
Oh, what the fuck?
Okay, that's fine.
Whatever
My is my drone doing shit?
I don't know don't are you droning are you are you droning
fucking this all right you're going down wait what did it
not hack i thought i hacked all
right goodbye i guess
hello please please keep hacking
All right.
There we go.
I don't even know if I'm doing any damage to it, but I am.
But I'm lasering.
Why does it not have eight health bars?
Wait, no, you're right.
Wait, no.
They'll run away, right?
Oh, it's gone.
Goodbye?
Maybe.
No, don't, no, I can't.
Don't worry, I'll make it leave.
I believe.
He'll leave.
He has to leave.
I believe.
He'll leave.
I'm not scared.
Don't worry.
He'll leave eventually.
Come on.
I know you want to come out.
Someone said he will eventually leave and I believe.
I believe.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
Look at all that damage though.
Look at all that damage.
Back off.
There we go.
Don't worry.
He'll leave.
Where am I?
Hurry!
Okay, it's fine, it's fine.
We're okay.
See, I told you.
Oh, he is.
Next to you.
He is.
He won't let me.
He is still here.
He is still here, guys.
He'll leave.
Guys, watch this.
He is gonna leave eventually.
No, Q.
I swear to...
Q.
Guys, he didn't leave.
Oh my god.
The checkpoint is so far.
But, oh.
There was no checkpoint.
I just realized.
I didn't get a checkpoint.
It's so far!
Oh my god, it's so far.
It's so fucking far.
I forgot.
What did you learn?
He didn't leave, guys.
I don't understand.
Why didn't he leave?
I thought he would leave
I'm gonna use the bathroom over here I'm
back I don't understand why didn't he leave I rock smoky
Medi Zechra bite on ya solid thank you for the super chat
thank you papa smurf thank you for the super chat oh my god
it's so far why didn't he leave me i did so much oh no okay
we're speed running this oh my god like they're like excuse
me you gotta clean the contamination and i'm like i'm
fucking out i'm outie all right i did go left last time
maybe this time i can go whoops not mean oh that was the
only way i can go never mind i thought all right we're speed
running did you always eat dinner with your family when i
was living with them yeah i'd come home after school and
tell them about my day oh up we go there were times when i
really ticked them off What did he do?
How did I do?
That's a secret.
I shall never learn.
Look at that.
He gave me a...
a money.
I'll grab that then.
Blast away and watch those bots kaboom!
Alright.
Alright, there you go.
See?
We're here now.
I told you guys we're gonna make it.
I told you guys.
Alright, fuck.
Alright, we gotta figure out how to deal with that goddamn
worm, I guess.
I guess I just run?
Like, what else can I do?
You got something?
Where's the worm?
Oh, now the worm does size the fucking oh now the worm oh oh
shit it was right behind me never mind i saw it is it god i
saw i saw the rocks
hello why won't it let me through no please okay there we go
okay i was gonna be like why is it not letting me through in
response to your inquiry writing excavation bots safety the
r d provides the following statement first the modern
question is equipped with a biometric id system and is
programmed to prioritize the avoidance of living beings
above all else additionally it's reinforced exterior not
only with sam's operational intent impact but also shields
the unit from unintended electromagnetic interference and
similar disruptions during routine lunar operations the risk
is considered negligible all right yeah let's go they are
but that system is now what's tracking us oh because we have
edus to thank for that too let's go stop skittering around
there you go
nice check that's right take this boom go my little drones
go
Take this!
My little drone's okay.
Oh shit.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Look at my little drones.
Go!
I definitely upgrade this drone more because he takes...
Does, like, the ammo It's not a lot, to be fair.
My little dragoons.
I feel like the ammo is not as much as it should be.
It's like a little weak.
Not gonna lie.
There's a loot here.
Oh, there is loot here.
God for the object scanner.
Little babies helping me.
Yay!
Taking my babies to war.
Let's go.
God indoctrinating them young.
Take my daughter to war day.
Alright, nice.
Oh, there's a word.
Can't get me.
That's right.
What you gonna do about that?
Oh, my little babies are gone.
That is not good.
Right on.
You're going down.
All right.
And Doki Bird, we trust.
Another one?
I can't wait to see what it is.
This is why RAM prices are so high.
My little daughter is hungry.
Can you blame her?
She's so hungry.
Oh, nice.
Thank God it's just finally.
Should we take a break?
No.
oh camera still works five no it's not enough it's not worth
it
there's still more web i'm already overwhelmed with all the
weapons i'm there's so many weapons to avoid humans a tragic
accident occurred recently fun latest sensor update all
systems are confirmed operational and work will continue as
scheduled always carry impact barriers sharing on-site
activities for safety there's so many options i guess it
like depends on what your play style is the magnet field
generated by impact barrier is detected by lunar digger
sensors as an unextractable object allowing you to
temporarily ward them up should a lunar digger behave
unexpectedly activate your impact barrier without hesitation
what the okay oh it's a defense Oh, so that's how I'm gonna
fight the worm.
All right.
It's weird having a barrier to keep us safe.
It's all right.
It's worm time.
Okay, let's go.
Wait, there's something.
What the?
Okay.
Don't get excavated.
We need to work on your jokes.
But wait, there's more.
Oh Fuck, okay Am I gonna get to
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
It is so fine
Can't get me that's right.
I'm on the platform I don't like this.
Okay, but there's loot right there Oh Oh,
surely he's not coming over.
Okay, okay, okay.
Slowly watching him approach me.
All right.
Oh, it's just that.
Oh, come on.
Yeah.
Why is this glow?
I guess it's like a new objective.
Maybe we can use it to trip up some bots.
Yeah, let's use it on the Luna Digger.
Alright, hello.
Oh, hello.
Be a shame if you...
He activated it already.
He activated it.
Alright.
That's totally fine.
I'm running for my life right now.
Whoa!
I beat it.
Not good luck.
Oh, the mines are timed.
Because of course they are!
Oh, what the fuck!
Reload.
I'm gonna just kill that right now.
Nice.
It's five.
Got open sesame.
Get out of here.
Alright, nice.
I need that extra heal too.
I don't like the stasis net.
Oh, alright.
I think I found a level that I hate more than the trees.
God.
I found it.
I hate this area more than the tree area for some fucking
reason.
There's just something about it.
Oh.
Of course.
Alright, we don't need any of these.
How bad could we possibly get?
I was like, that's...
It's fine.
I'm out of the tree level.
Now I'm in the...
I mean, to be fair, I should have assumed we're going to be
in the space level.
It is...
It is space.
space sweet i'll make a solid pudding containers are pretty
useful huh it's just well where i hear him oh there he is
all right it's just there's an unkillable worm that wants to
kill me like what do I do oh my god I can't even get I can't
even loot to my content wait how do I what's the point of
opening this container I swear to God okay there you Oh my
god, it was just for loot.
That's fine
Oh, he's coming closer Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh, thank god, cutsy
Is that a warehouse?
Let's go find a way inside Oh my god, I almost went the
other way Come on, grab the decoy gun The barrier does
nothing for me It does Okay, it does Ah.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, I like how there's an alien guarding all of that too.
Fuck, okay, let me analyze the situation.
No, Q.
Okay.
Let's go over here.
Wait.
What am I supposed to do with that guy?
Oh shit, okay.
All right, fuck you, I guess.
Fuck this guy.
There you go.
oh please tell me i make it please it's okay he doesn't know
okay okay we made it we made it we fucking made it
why is that sound look out good job kenny you're going down
okay thank god thank god he's going down
Oh What are you gonna do about it huh you can't fucking even
get up here?
Oh, please tell me actually can't get up here.
Please tell me just walk you slowly
There we go Thank god
He actually can't get up here Yo, is there something down
here
Oh, fuck.
I see loot.
All right.
That's fine.
Oh, that is fine.
All right, that's fine.
Oh, it's okay.
Decoy though.
Decoy.
Oh.
Oh, it's okay, decoy!
Oh, there is- oh, okay, that's fine.
It's alright, we made it, we made it.
I'm safe here.
What the fuck?
Let's keep things up.
Over-tried- Alright, that's it.
Go hack.
I heal.
All right, there we go.
Okay, that was a lot of damage.
Now we got a way across.
Yeah, I didn't even realize how close I was to dying until
now.
Oh, okay, that's fine.
All right, let's...
Come on, fuck this guy.
I'm gonna kill him just for it.
Get him!
She's fucking, uh, he's so confused.
He is so fucking confused.
He's so fucking confused.
Oh, he know.
But loot.
It's okay.
He's not gonna come over.
There you go.
See, I told you.
I'm so safe.
Oh, but there's...
It's money.
Oh, it can't catch me.
Do it for the money.
I will say, it's not as bad as the forest level now.
Now that I'm more...
Now that I'm more like...
I have more playtime on this area.
It's not as bad as the...
I still don't like the forest more.
This is alright.
now that more experience in this area not as bad I'm more
used to it now let's check it up all right we're going back
to the shelter though all
right let us oh my god there's so much upgrades I didn't
realize not as bad for now for now all right let's all in on
the child let's go Okay, I guess I could upgrade a little
bit of HP.
Okay, now I want to...
Why have that drone...
Oh, fuck, I was supposed to upgrade my other stuff.
Sorry.
I went all in on the drone.
I forgot about...
Ah, shit, okay.
I forgot about my other stuff.
That was like, all in!
New training sim data has arrived!
All right, be sure to give it a try.
We'll pick a random one.
Oh, it's just lawyer.
We hope you enjoy your purchase.
All right, Dan, do you have anything to say?
That lunedigger came out of nowhere.
Let me guess.
Edis built these damn worms too, didn't it?
There's always the space worm.
Lunediggers have been helping out of the cradle for ages.
Every time you're on the moon, there's always a space worm.
And suits making decisions around here really rubbed me the
wrong way.
It's like space 101.
you go to space there's a worm every time you can never
escape the worm all right I'll never I guess I'll never use
a new node he was it it was multi hack I do like oh 300 oh
my god there's so much more weapons I haven't unlocked yet
there's so many areas okay all right I'm locked in I am
getting more overwhelmed oh wait hey oh hey more rim God
fucking of course how am I supposed to move that
Oh my god, I thought that was glass.
I thought that was glass.
I was so...
I...
Fuck.
Do I want...
Okay, let's go.
I have a key anyway.
Oh.
Nope.
Now it's mine.
Right on.
Oh my god, my drone is so strong.
Yes, that's that.
Okay.
Oh my god.
That's not what I wanted.
No!
There we go.
God, they're so tanky.
Nice.
Wait, where am I?
Where am I?
Oh my god, Cap, I missed.
Okay.
Jesus Christ, they're so tanky.
They're always so tanky.
take it oh
my god please
oh thank god
jesus christ are they they're not dead he is so he is so
healthy
all right thank god i got critical though this
is my turn holy this is built from the moon this is actually
built from the moon who would have thought take this jesus
they're so tanky it's like a damage sponge there's more
I Okay, okay give you a sec Oh my god, I'm ulting I thought
that was the end It really did felt like end game Oh my
god I can't believe there's still more
Yeah That's fine
I'll take that.
Oh, whoa I'll take that.
I'm gonna run to you.
Do a critical.
All right, that's fine.
Oh, oh, I didn't even notice this guy.
He was just chilling.
Take this.
And then last one.
Yeah, let's do this.
All right, there you go.
has to be the last one nice oh I no more I'm broke I printed
all of it I'm all printed my all my filament here all right
eat your ramstick girl oh Diana go keep eating that Ram okay
nice okay she can hack more now all right we made it all
right new mechanic we push oh no these okay there is a limit
to the push
hello I got my Engineering Expo tomorrow.
I've been really nervous, so thank you for helping me relax
on your stream.
Thank you for the Super Chat Sleepy.
Good luck with your good luck with your Engineering Expo.
I believe in you.
I believe in you more than I believe in myself right now and
trying to figure out this goddamn puzzle.
Okay.
Why won't you?
Why are you locked?
Oh, it's here.
That's why.
I figured it out.
All right.
Oh, it's butterflies.
See, I told you I believe in you.
Look, if I could figure this out, you can figure every...
You can do well in your engine.
Oh my god, not you.
Please, I don't have anything.
Right on.
Now it's my turn.
Oh my god.
don't have any please all right there you go how did you
fail how how
yeah you know what I'm just gonna hone it down
okay guys great goodbye good fuck oh good fucking oh Good
fucking father.
There you go eventually eventually he was gonna die
eventually I swear to God this better not be a puzzle I
Wonder if you're all filled with limb the material inside
seems fresh nothing refined like lunath element.
Oh No, no Oh, no Oh Oh Oh Oh
All right, there better not be anything next to here Okay,
nice I figured it out Look at that I perforced it Didn't
even need to try technically
I'm detecting a mod All right Well, when you put it that
way, how can I resist?
All right.
Stasis net, charge piercer.
Well, we need a third gun.
So despite how much I hate the stasis net, we need a third
gun.
All right.
I guess.
Oh!
To ensure safety, access to this storage area is restricted
to all Oh
It's five got a shotgun.
That's fine Oh, thank God I had a shotgun.
Thank fuck you guys
What the fuck is that?
What the fuck?
It has four boobs.
Oh Shit, they're not boobs That's right, we're gonna do now.
That's goddamn right.
Okay.
That's fine.
Are you
fucking kidding me?
There you go.
Oh!
All right You're kidding.
Oh my god.
All right.
That's it.
That's it I think I had that oh There's just how the fuck am
I gonna all right.
That's it
We did it Oh Not as hard as I thought because I kept my ult.
Saving my ult is always the play.
How the...
Puzzle!
Alright.
Puzzle time.
Ah.
Fuzz.
This will make my hacking a bit harder.
Okay, it's this way.
Alright.
Oh, not too bad.
It's a one-step puzzle.
Nice.
I love it when my puzzle is only one step.
I'm glad I had the barrier, too.
Barrier came in clutch.
What?
How do I get out?
Eh.
Now what?
What do I do with that?
Oh.
I guess that?
How do I get that?
Oh.
What?
Question mark?
I'm detecting a mod.
all right let's go grab it well when you put it that way how
can i resist maybe here okay all right here anyway at least
we can grab that how important is that loot over here hmm
i'm gonna grab this first but how important is that other
thing I can't open it from here.
I can't open it from...
Where the fuck do I open this?
Oh, here!
There you go.
Alright, look at that.
I'm so goddamn smart.
Goddamn.
I am a genius.
Alright, stuff I don't need.
Let's go.
Okay.
Oh.
More upgrades.
I was hoping we'd find this.
I need to print.
Oh, I definitely need to print more guns.
I'll grab the shotgun.
Is it true Dr. Higgins brought his daughter's biometric data
into the lab?
From what I heard is only...
That has to be Diana.
Daisy?
Diana?
D's it all connects now who the fuck is eight I guess I
think eight has to come from the same DNA as Daisy and then
we're all just replicas of date like it's just all Daisy
replicas all right so everything and if it works the results
wouldn't be as impressive I'm pretty sure we're all built
off of Daisy so the Doctor had a daughter Daisy That name
ring a bell I think When I got the stop code from 8 I also
got some data from her memory Dr. Higgins made us both To
help with his research So he's the one that created Pragmeta
I knew it We all come from Daisy Daisy Prime I It's like
Astro Boy.
Oh my god, is Daisy dead?
Wait, Daisy could be dead.
Alright, where is this little guy going now?
Oh, hey there, I see you.
How did he see me?
God damn it, so goddamn windows still.
Is there something above me?
No.
Wait, how do I get there?
I gotta push it.
Okay.
Sneaky, sneaky.
A little hidden hidden loot right here.
So goddamn sneaky.
I thought I didn't see.
Oh.
All right, goodbye They
got the heat
Hello, oh shit Oh my god, what is that What the fuck?
Oh shit, I need to crit that
Oh my god you're still alive?
I didn't think you'd still be alive.
Not gonna lie.
Wait, can I crit that?
No.
Now I can.
I can't even hear him.
It's just a giant boy.
How do they make zero sound?
Alright.
Parkour.
Now he's dead.
thank god evil has been defeated oh my god so fuck there's
so many boxes who's gonna clean this up later more
containers with panels it seems like your kind of thing why
i don't like this i mean it's all hacking and puzzles and
stuff right okay why can't my daughter auto hack all of this
the underlying.
Okay, okay, I get it.
Okay.
Alright, I can do this.
I can do all these puzzles.
I need to do that one too?
Huh?
Now what?
Oh no.
Oh, no.
I hear him.
Where are you?
I hear you.
Oh my god.
What do I do?
Wait, where do I do?
Okay.
Maybe?
Now what?
Please.
Maybe?
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Alright, I got loot.
Aww.
Where is he?
Oh, there you are.
Bingo
Oh, I get over there Oh, no My little rocket ship legs
I don't know I don't know
I don't know I don't know What do I do?
I'm stuck
What do I do?
Oh, I'm too stupid for this.
Okay.
All right, I can figure this out.
I didn't do this, Stokie.
It's not that hard.
Move this.
Got it.
And then we move this.
And then...
We do this, and then...
Oh my god, I'm so fucking smart.
JK.
Look at that.
I baited you guys.
I knew exactly what I was doing all along.
So easy.
I lured you in a false sense of security.
Be like, dokey, dot, dot, dot.
Just to prove you guys all wrong.
okay nice what training sims did we get just so you guys
would feel more impressed with my big brain should we take a
break all right how much do we get oh yeah that's a lot of
filament let's go back okay now we can actually upgrade our
nodes and stuff that's what we actually really needed
I think we actually Wait, do you guys think we would finish
this game today?
Alright, one.
Alright, we need to grab the mod slot.
It's really needed that.
Oh, there's a thruster.
Fire!
I didn't see the thruster.
What do I need for thruster?
15,000?
No?
I thought it was so close.
I legitimately was like, Oh my god, we're gonna make it.
We're gonna make it.
you know wait for quite some time yeah i'm trying to force
myself to like sleep in the actual decent time if i put it
just streaming longer that was a lot of container moving
it's a big bring in the room with us now lord kerosos thank
you the super chat thank you thank you i got through the
level didn't i maybe
even a cat a cat all right somebody fed my ai false
information Who added?
All those containers wasted on piles of- Who added a fan
Wikipedia into your- into your brain?
When were all the refined Luna filament got to?
Maybe Edis is using it to make more bots.
You know?
You're probably right.
It doesn't make any sense that it would disappear like that.
We gotta knock some sense into Edis before it burns through
it all.
Alright.
Now play with the new toy I made you.
I like how it's like Oh, I like how everything's connected
here Wait, what did I give her?
I didn't give her that, right?
I did.
I forgot what I gave her.
It's all blurring together.
I bought her too many toys.
She's very spoiled.
What is a good node?
Uh, but damage Increases.
I don't think I'm attacking people if I'm behind.
Maybe collateral damage?
Or skirmisher?
I feel like collateral...
Crit smash?
That's collateral damage, right?
I'll do collateral damage.
Or I feel like that's the best one.
Yeah, yeah.
All right, I need to print my new weapons, guys.
Back to the printing board.
All right, let's go.
Yeah, I'm trying to build on crit and heat right now.
I definitely need to upgrade.
I need to upgrade thrusters next, and then if I have to crit
after that, so I can have more crit nodes.
oh no not the outside no more boxes yeah oh here's a box
thing supposed to be a mining rig there's another box i
thought you said no more boxes hugh
he lied to never trust never trust a guy named hugh
Unauthorized access to cleanly equipment.
Oh, there's another box.
Oh, no.
They can fly.
Oh, wait.
They've always been able to fly.
Oh, they're orange now.
What do you mean they're orange now?
What do you mean?
Get ready.
Linking the enemy.
All right.
I know.
Why are they orange?
It's over.
A photon laser.
Am I just waiting?
Oh shit, yeah, they're sending more people in.
It's the elevator.
It's the elevator part of the game.
There's always an elevator part of the game.
It's only when you had a unit that could delete nodes.
Is he deleting it?
Right on.
Okay.
Oh, nice.
Let's go.
I only did that much that- okay, I am heavily relying on
crit right now.
Holy shit.
I actually- I only did that much damage out of everything.
Okay, it's live.
There we go.
I'm actually, it's just all crit.
Another crit!
Let's go, thank God for crit!
Oh, fuck, I'm sorry.
I owe you one.
Back off!
Alright.
There we go.
Where am I?
We're in my...
Nice.
He got confused.
That's good.
There's a crit there, too.
One last crit for the road.
Let's...
Oh, never mind.
JK.
JK, we're in for...
What?
Now it's one last.
crit oh never mind surely one last crit for the ride there
we go sorry there's there's a lot of crits there we go oh
wait there's more you thought that was the last crit on the
road we have one last crit for the road
that there's that's not a boss but it was just a very very
fucking tanky ship
that's everything that we almost died yeah even now we're
the same we're like um diana you might be building metal but
i'm very very fleshy
I should... No, no, take me back.
Take me back.
I realize I have... I need to print more guns.
I was like, HP, I'm fine, but I need to print more ammo real
quick.
Alright, let's go print.
Air Raiders really zoom around fast, huh?
She really wants to play.
Let's play hide and seek again.
You won't find me this time.
I know.
My poor flesh.
Alright.
Oh.
Where is she?
Oh, she's getting better at this.
Over here?
Wait, she's getting better.
I don't see her.
Oh my gosh, she hid in this.
She did the same hiding spot.
She's like, he'll never...
He'll never...
never expect me to hide here again.
God damn it.
She almost got me.
She really did.
Oh no.
I forgot to put the RC car away.
Come to think of it.
How's that thing running?
Batteries included?
Hmm.
Not sure.
I thought it was charging for...
It's a meta spot.
It's the hide and see spot, Doki.
Never expect me to hide here again.
again and I didn't I almost didn't but then she she needs to
learn not to tell me where she is around I guess that kind
of setup's a no-brainer all right
all right here we go all right I need to upgrade
get the thruster we need that thruster we need that extra
charge and then We'll grab the honing missile.
Honing missile is fine.
The thing that worries me is that I still have more stuff to
print.
We're at the...
What was it?
Second last level?
And I have four more guns that I still don't have?
Like, that worries me a little bit.
Oh my god!
What do you mean I still have four more guns?
Shockwave gun.
Alright, we're ready.
We're ready to go in.
Alright, here we go.
I can make it.
I feel like every gun I find is like So unique too.
Oh, please don't tell me space room is back.
Please don't tell me space room is back.
Please, please.
Space room.
Space room?
I think we're getting pretty close.
Space room.
You can see the Earth's so wet from here.
Yep.
Nice and clear shot at home.
Okay, that's good.
It's lore.
Oh, that's beautiful.
Down there, every place has its own kind of color you know
everything about the earth don't you i've always been into
space when space there will be a word all over searching for
places with the best views and clear skies went all the way
to the namib desert once is that unusual maybe a bit
adventurous for some but my parents supported me the whole
way oh told me to do what i I mean, he gets, he gets to be
an astronaut.
And you learn, it's not enough to hear or read about a
thing.
Sometimes you gotta live it.
Hugh, I want to go too.
Go where?
To all the places you've been.
Oh.
All of them?
That's a lot of places.
Then let's do it.
Whoa, Hugh.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
I'm a good dad.
If she wants to go to Disneyland, we'll take her to
Disneyland.
Look at that.
Well, when you put it that way, how can I resist?
Oh, yeah.
Parent of the Year.
Oh, fuck.
No.
Oh, wait, here.
Nah.
Would you still love me if I was a giant space worm?
Hmm.
And please wait seven to eight business days for our plot.
Sneaking into places we aren't supposed to be.
It's alright, everyone's dead anyway, so it's fine.
We can use that back at the shelter.
That will make you hit harder while in low gravity.
I need time to think about it.
How big of a space worm are you?
This is a lab.
Or at least it was.
Maybe the lunaticer did this.
I don't know if I told you this story.
I saw in a tweet about how like they broke up with their
boyfriend.
because like the person asked that like would you still love
me if I was a worm and then the boyfriend was like no but
I'll keep you as a but I'll keep you as a pet so then like
and then you can see me with my new girlfriend I'll keep you
as a pet so you'll be safe but then I was like geez
the worst answer he could give yeah then they broke i'm not
surprised they broke up after that at least he's on this
yeah it's giving you it's like a pet in a little in a little
glass cage and then you see you see him with his new
girlfriend what's going on with my suit is it this black
goop We definitely need the multi.
What the fuck?
Yeah.
I don't like all these black loot.
Oh, is he gonna get...
He's gonna get... God, fucking...
He got loot.
Oh, shit!
Okay, that's not even...
That's not even 3D pr- Oh, what?
Oh, it's like it slows me down.
It's not even 3D printed anymore.
Okay.
It's so slow.
He got goopy.
I'm not so sure.
It's like slime.
I think it's that black stuff that's doing this.
First Edis, now mysterious black goop.
Wait, can I get that?
My suit's acting up again.
This doesn't seem like a typical case of suit.
There's something below.
I can't be bothered.
I'm going to go fly over there.
Okay.
What?
Lower time.
Good morning.
FYI, routine inspection, and access log audits will begin
shortly at the...
Oh, at the Nexus Tower.
Please note that internal communication communication within
the tower will be offline.
So responses may be delayed during this period.
Great.
Now that ticket I scored for Galactica's medal final world
tour is wasted.
Front row arena seats.
I'll never just scalp...
I'm just sorry.
Do not endorse scalping.
VR stream just can't match the real thing.
No, don't tell me.
The station AI is scanning my thoughts.
Can't even daydream about my favorite bandit piece.
I should have never came to the moon.
Damn.
It's gonna miss Zegel lack of concert.
I still can't open that yet.
Oh!
Guess we have to go this way now.
Oh, hey.
Another red key.
Let's go.
That should give us access to our red sub.
Did you get a chance to look at the files?
Oh.
Five.
More time.
I mean that one about a mysterious substance that dissolves
organic matter.
Based on those results, we could be i mean i don't know
we've been handling them now for like what years they
wouldn't hide to me that serious now would they but there's
always the possibility we could be working i wouldn't worry
about it anyway isn't that time to change shifts yeah wait
what working what what is your sentence give me the
exposition that way you'll carry us at high oh my god we
don't even know what we're working on how do you record
something but then give no context what's the point of
recording what's the point of recording if you don't give
any context about the information they're so vague what is
it big boy I'm too scared engagement by me
Get into the Nexus Tower.
Goddamn vague.
Yeah, worst lie.
Welcome to the Nexus Tower.
Entrance to the tower.
Goddamn vague posting.
Scared you might say something.
It will result in an immediate termination.
Thanks for the warm welcome.
I'll see myself in.
Termination like fired, right?
Oh my god.
Oh.
My god.
Fuck that shit.
I'm done.
I'm calling it here.
I look down and there's too much stuff down there.
It's future turkey's problem.
I'm ready to call it there.
I'm going home.
I'm groping out.
I don't know.
Either a worm's gonna come out of there, or just I gotta
fight a lot of people, and I didn't like either option.
I...
But we're almost done.
You're not.
Gus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't keep listening.
I have critical information about the black group.
It's thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Or it could be both.
You're right.
It could be both.
Yeah, I had fun.
time i think i like this okay i will be i won't be honest
with you guys i like this game but i think they have a they
they do have a weird scaling issue i think like i don't know
maybe i'm just putting my stuff on the wrong upgrades but
like their scaling wise is like more like it's just tankier
enemies and that's the one thing it's like that bothers me
the most it's just the enemies are way too tanky you have to
uh it could be my build though i'm not sure if it's my build
or just they just feel like bullet sponge but like i put it
all on hacking and gun i
it's i put it i don't even fucking try to do hp anymore i
just go gun hack
So, I don't, I can't tell.
I can't tell if it's just, but when I did the critical
build, it did help a lot.
Yeah, I'm using the critical heat build right now.
And, and it's, it's, it is getting a lot faster now.
Like, I'm killing enemies a lot faster.
But, yeah, it's just, maybe my guns need to be stronger as
well, question mark.
But right now, I do feel like that's my only issue.
with the game is that the enemies are just so tanky.
The longer you progress.
And like, I gotta shoot them a lot.
Check the bingo guns.
You're right.
It's time for bingo.
new data has arrived.
Be sure to give it a try.
Bingo.
What is this?
Oh, it's I'll grab another heal.
Fuck it.
Might as well.
All in on heals.
Oh, yes.
This is one of our more popular items.
I don't need any of these, though.
And that's the thing.
It's just all cosmetics.
But I'll grab this.
I use max upgrade, decode, and shotgun all game in the big
enemies.
Oh, yay.
New clothes.
Oh, that's nice.
a gift and give her a new shirt to inform you that we do not
offer any i like her cute actually what does it look like
you enjoy your purchase what does it look like oh yeah that
thing all right diana new trip i should i do like this one
more look at you go i actually like the black outfit more
than the blue one because then it doesn't look like I don't
care about her, you know, like you know, because the blue
one, the default one is like ripped apart and like, you
know, scratched up, so at least this one looks like I
actually bought her clothes, you know, like I mean, it's
nice, too.
It has a little Genji hat, too.
I've been playing with that.
Yeah, actually treat her, like, I actually bought her
clothes.
all right yeah child support is gonna take you away now
thank god all right i'm gonna call it here uh i'm having fun
i think i can finish this next playthrough most likely i'm
pretty sure because it's like i'm already halfway in this
area and there's still like the one last area left so i'm
pretty sure next week i can finish this game uh i just need
one more playthrough of it But yeah, like, that's just my...
I think that's my only critique.
Um, that's my only critique of this game.
It's just, I feel like...
Maybe it's just my build, but it just...
You have to find the right build to, like, shred the enemies
faster.
Because right now, like, I found the right build to crit,
but it's still...
I have to get to the crit part.
Like, I have to...
Like, when I just try to shoot my gun, I barely did anything
to the robots.
the bots but then the moment i hit the crit then i hit like
3k damage yeah yeah so i think i guess you don't want to
make it too easy but it just feels like some of them are
just bullet sponges yeah anyway guys it's so fun i do like
the mechanics a lot um it's just just the enemies in general
yeah um um going all in a diet but she's my investment
Anyway guys, as always everybody, stay hydrated, posture
check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.